quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats des
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur les tickets vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream alors aujourd'hui match choc
entre fabiolocarona avec les Blancs
donc un match qu'on attendait tous
depuis très longtemps qu'on carwana qui
est qui est un joueur qui est dans le
top 5 mondial on va dire depuis de
nombreuses années qui a très très
longtemps occupé d'ailleurs le deuxième
poste
le deuxième poste mondial
et bien sûr absenterov qui qui a un
jeune
âgé seulement de 18 ans qui fait partie
de la de la jeune génération qui monte
en flèche donc Abdou qui a déjà gagné un
champion de chasse
donc franchement match hyper hyper chaud
les joueurs qui sont déjà beaucoup de
fois sur internet je sais pas du tout je
sais pas du tout
quels sont les pronostics pour
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est cette
ultra serré comme match
j'ai presque envie de donner
Abdou en favori ce serait vraiment le le
gros le gros Paris mais c'est pas clair
du tout en tout cas donc salut à tous
sur le chat salut Axel salut le Nao
salut graines de Suisse Mick pogneur
tyran et rigolo qui sont sur le chat
pour l'instant donc des parties
commencent normalement à 19h donc 5
minutes donc on va attendre un petit peu
car voilà on aura les blancs dans cette
première partie donc rapidement comment
se passe le tournoi en fait
vous avez je vais vous montrer un peu le
bracket regardez le braquet qui est ici
avec tous les joueurs on a Nakamura qui
a éliminé youngui lors du premier tour
du final là on a car Wana qui affronte
Abdou pour ce weekend du final aussi et
pour rejoindre Naka en car donc c'est
pas forcément une nouvelle mais bon il
faut quand même gagner le match ça rime
qui a battu Sarana 16-10 quand un peu
écrasant qui passe en car et demain nous
aurons le match mvl contre goutesh pour
rejoindre Sarine en quart de finale on a
encore quinzaine vite qui aura lieu
demain aussi donc demain c'est grosses
journées avec mvl gouquettes et
certaines vies pour arriver aussi en
quart de finale avec nepo qui a un
époque qui qui remplace Ding alors
dinkina pas voulu pour vous dire qu'il
avait autobus autre chose à faire je ne
sais pas
participer à l'événement il était
inscrit de base il était remplacé par
dépôt donc nepo qui va jouer contre
ici pour une place aussi en car pour
jouer contre une Carcel serait un beau
match et Ali Reza qui a gagné sur le fil
contre André Keane qui va jouer contre
saut aussi en quart de finale donc là ce
tournoi en fait si vous voulez c'est une
élimination directe c'est à dire que dès
que je perds un match et ben je suis
éliminé c'est pas comme le Championship
tour ou ben quand je perds et ben je
peux rejouer et j'ai encore une chance
vous voyez là il y a pas du tout de
chance tu perds un match ça va voilà
donc là on a des joueurs qui ne va pas
partir on a eu yangi qui est éliminé on
a Sarana qui est éliminé et on a aronyan
ainsi que André King éliminé voilà donc
aujourd'hui on va couvrir le match
carwana à zetorov donc il y aura un
genre à éliminé après ce match là et en
joueur qui sera qualifié en quart pour
joue contre Nakamura donc c'est pas un
cadeau c'est pas un cadeau mais mais bon
c'est toujours quand même cool quart de
finale et donc la cadence alors je vais
vous montrer un petit peu tout ce que
j'ai ici
pour la cadence je crois que c'était ici
en format là non ça c'est les points pas
mal d'événement voilà c'est les points
et je pense pas que j'ai une avec avec
ça et c'est pas grave je vais revenir
sur ma scène avec les joueurs et je vous
explique tout comme ça donc vous avez
90 minutes mais c'est écrit en dessous
de moi j'avais juste en dessous c'est
écrit 90 minutes de 5 + 1
ensuite on réduit le temps on fait une
heure deux trois plus une
et ensuite on fera une demi-heure de une
plus jeune donc ça marche sur trois
heures une heure et demie plus 1h une
demi-heure trois heures et en cas
d'égalité il y aura quatre parties de
une plus une
et couleur alternat à chaque fois et en
cas d'égalité il y aura un magasin c'est
une partie
ultime qui va départager le match parce
qu'on passe à partager jusqu'à la
jusqu'à enfin toute la nuit quoi donc il
faut une partie en magasin donc c'est
voilà c'est un match qui s'annonce être
très très serré
mais à voir avoir parce que on avait on
avait commenté un match aussi très serré
c'était le match de saut contre aronial
qui normalement est extrêmement serré
mais ce à gagner 7,5
lors du 5 + 1 ce qui a quasiment plus le
match d'entrée de jeu quoi donc avoir
donc c'est un match qui normalement
devrait être assez close donc assez
serré mais voyons voir un peu la forme
des joueurs avant tout et en tout cas
abdouk c'est un genre qui qui est
capable de battre car wash c'est un
joueur qui est qui est extrêmement
dangereux
et
Caruana c'est un joueur bon c'est le
numéro deux mondial depuis de nombreuses
et nombreuses années
pour moi personnellement c'est le Clair
numéro 2 après Magnus
sur internet il a eu pendant très
longtemps un peu de mal et après pendant
le confinement il est tellement tournois
sur internet que il a été obligé de se
mettre à jour sur Internet et à
progresser et maintenant en blitz rapide
et même sur Internet et ben il a
beaucoup progressé donc on va voir un
petit peu ce que ça marche va donner
mais c'est un match qui est pour moi
ultra
compliqué d'ailleurs j'ai donc j'avais
un Excel qui nous avait été donné par
parescom je vais voir si je peux y avoir
accès parce qu'il nous donnait toutes
les
je sais pas si je vais ici
non c'est pas celui-là faut que je
trouve sur stack il donnait en fait
toutes les
[Musique]
les prédictions du
donc c'est pas ça des matchs donc ce
qu'il disait ce qu'il pensait
alors je vais retrouver ça c'est
intéressant de voir ce que disait
Jessica
je crois que c'est ça
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr mais je regarde
oui c'est ça
ok ok donc j'ai le truc je regardais
en score total qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et vous du score fin de si vous
avez un peu des prédictions à donner ou
un pourcentage sur sur le joueur
qu'est-ce que vous donneriez vous comme
pourcentage
car voilà par exemple il aurait combien
est-ce que pour vous Carona aurait plus
de 50 % de chance de gagner un match
qui est favori selon vous dans le dans
ce dans ce match
moi j'ai ma propre opinion et j'ai aussi
l'opinion de cheescom parce que ben j'ai
sous les yeux le tableau qui ont été
faits par les experts
et
les parties a commencé la première
partie a commencé déjà à
l'heure donc 19h il y a un peu de retard
et là il y a pas de retard c'est assez
ça va assez vite 14 11 pour Kawana
carnass à 30% salut madame salut à tous
ceux qui arrivent sur sur le chat X à
droite à l'option C5
[Musique]
55% en faveur de Carola et 45 pour Abdou
moi j'aurais dit plutôt l'inverse moi je
pense que Abdou
il peut vraiment être fort
on va voir en tout cas comment il joue
c'est qu'un ensemble de Blitz
[Musique]
en été joué il y a un clouage une
pression sur le pion ça 5
d'ailleurs vous dire exactement un peu
ce qui se passe
il donne
[Musique]
14,5
c'est quoi
c'est le record
OK
S
[Musique]
ah oui en fait il donne quatre et demi 4
ans et demi en 5 + 1 5 4 en 3 + 1 et 5 5
en 1 + 1 en fait c'est comme aussi est
d'accord pour dire que c'est un match
qui est extrêmement
extrêmement serré
vraiment très serré c'est vraiment la
jeunesse qui vient essayer de
détrôner on va dire l'expérience
Caravana je vais voir s'il y a moyen de
de
remonter un peu la tête de Fabiano parce
qu'il est un petit peu bas je sais pas
si je peux remonter un peu
ouais je l'emporte un petit peu là
des fois les joueurs et ben ils ont les
camarades ils sont un peu basses donc on
peut pas trop trop
la remonter le même là je suis au max
alors dessin qui a été joué
je vois bien que les gens
ouais c'est chaud en vrai c'est c'est
intéressant mais il faut il faut en tout
cas bien commencer je pense au match
et parce que bon là on voit déjà qu'il y
a deux minutes d'avance dans la première
partie et en plus
car voilà qui a une bonne position je
pense je travaille
direct sur F4 direct voilà kg j'ai pas
peur qui vient de manger 4 souvent on
fait je crois pour empêcher 4 puis on
fait F4 dans ce cas là il a pas peur
parce qu'en fait ça sert à rien ça sert
je pousse et ça a l'air d'aller
c'est aussi le bleu
comment vas-tu c'est le vendu
sur le match ouais d'ailleurs si vous
voulez on peut faire des petits des
petits Paris prédictions pour ceux qui
auraient envie de de parier vos vos
points de chaîne sur sur le match
qu'est-ce que vous pensez regardez je
vais vous mettre un petit première
prédiction
sur
[Musique]
le gain du du premier set
prédiction je vais vous mettre
bien du 5 + 1
donc c'est un 7 en entier
[Musique]
si je fais une prédiction que je mets
trois raisins possibles et des points
non
il n'y a pas de points je crois que
c'est allez je vous mets je vous mets 5
minutes
vous avez 5 minutes pour pour voter ce
que vous ce que vous voulez parce que
vous pensez que voilà va gagner ce 7
est-ce que vous pensez que Abdou va
gagner le 7 ou est-ce que vous pensez
que personne ne va gagner le 7 il y aura
égalité sur ce match je vous laisse à
vos paris vous avez 5 minutes pour
parier je vois
plein de monde qui parient sur kerwana
moi si je pouvais parier j'aurais parié
sur Abdou parce que je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai un feeling mais après voilà ça
regarde que moi mais
je dois gagner une partie
c'est la meilleure version du monde
c'est pas
c'est pas un hasard c'est pas un hasard
je vais essayer de me mettre un peu dans
la gauche
manuellement c'est la flemme de bouger
la chaise vous prenez alors
dans les noirs
allez je vous laisse parier vous avez
encore quelques minutes pour parier sur
le gain du 7 donc c'est pas de cette
partie là c'est le 7 en entier donc il y
aura 1h30 de de
5 + 1
pourquoi plus de
comment ça plus de
jouer
et qui réfléchit prendre sa décision en
B4 5 ou qui a l'air intéressant pour
empêcher ce qu'avait de venir en ce 5 et
ne pas trop ouvrir le jeu
c'est sûrement le coup que je ferai moi
c'est le coup qui a été joué d'ailleurs
bon c'est pas bon goût
c'est pour ça que je l'aurais joué mais
ça a l'air logique en fait ça a l'air
logique B4 donc je suis à 5 à 3 et prise
voilà
le speed chef c'est plus un rue et la
cadence c'est une seconde une seconde
parcours ça a l'air
t'inquiète moi je peux aussi battre NACA
avec la fille
de la famille alors E4 a été joué
j'aime bien les blancs quand même là un
jour une poussée au 5 F5 peut arriver
qu'avait les B5 qui poussent arriver un
jour taper sur les pions ici empêcher la
pousser là échanger des fous de
quasiment
pas mal donc il y a peut-être 32 qui va
venir clouer ce fou et t'inquiète deux
fois ça peut être un gros problème le
centre a été joué et B5 ça j'y pensais
arriver
tellement bien il est noir aussi peuvent
toujours bouger un peu c'est vrai que
les pièces blanches sont quand même
largement mieux mais quand même du jeu
donc faire attention il faut essayer de
contenir le jeu des blancs
ça ira
je sais pas si une belle joue beaucoup
la vie d'or ça m'étonnerait
donc c'est pas c'est un tout recettes
alors logique l'ordinateur qui n'aime
pas trop ce coup allez H5 et en fait le
jeu des blancs assez facile
ce qui va jouer
beaucoup de temps et on voit que
l'ordinateur il met que des points
d'interrogation à chaque coup et bon il
rate des choses tactiques je pense
quelque part mais je sais pas comment
alors E5 c'est un coup qui peut se jouer
je pense puis on prend et S5 thématique
dans cette position
essayez vous de fermer un peu les
colonnes pour ramener les pièces en
quatre et un F5 c'est un coup de
thématique dans tout ce qui est
dans tout ce qui est Benoni pour
attaquer un peu
ça va être un problème
il y a pas le
il y a pas les valeurs
il y a pas les
la barre malheureusement
[Musique]
j'ai un peu du mal à l'enlever je peux
peut-être vous l'enlever mais je vais me
faire peut-être engueuler je crois que
c'est quand même bien garder les balles
cavaliers
et surprise du cavalier avait la prise
ici échec et qui allait manger la tour
ici
je vais vous l'enlever
vous allez grandir
un peu
allez je voulais enlever
alors
plein de maths de partout
la cavalier prend des 5 peut être un
coup prise
ok d'un bouge attention à fourchette
là ça sent que la tactique de partout
roi H1
2 sens c'est hyper compliqué il y a tout
en prison mais toi en prise quand même
chez les Noirs
il y a pas de suite
d'un message je prends là on pousse les
pions ça a l'air terminé
tout rêve de
et là c'est terminé quoique
je peux pas
ça fait nul c'est nul pas répétition
famille qui a bien
bien
spi haut
il était il était écrasant et ça fait
nul
des fois je me l'enlève juste pour moi
j'ai pas les cames ouais ouais bon après
après moi je vous avais gardé mais
c'était plus pour parce que tu es comme
les demandes
c'est pour ça que j'avais gardé les
ventes toujours l'évaluation les gens
aiment bien avoir un peu le spectacle et
voir la jauge qui qui monte et qui
descend
mais c'est vrai que
quand on commande des parties c'est
mieux de pas l'avoir du tout et de
d'essayer juste de
jouer chaque quoi
en C4
tu vois Valmy qui aime bien les vagues
il y a tout il faut tout on va essayer
d'alterner un petit peu
[Musique]
on va essayer de mettre un petit peu
oui bien sûr il y a encore il y a mvl
qui joue demain contre kookesh et on a
Annie résa qui est passé hein déjà en
quart de finale et qui va affronter
Wesley lors de son prochain match je
sais pas encore les dates mais dès qu'on
le sera
donc pour éviter les jouets 80 pas mal
c'est pas le mieux de suite d'un point
ici mais il va y avoir fois 6
probablement et on s'active avec nos
pièces pas si clair
d'un point C4
ici puis on prend un téléphone
de faire quoi que ce soit
ok mais bon ça change pas grand chose en
fait les noirs sont assez actif ici
mais bon oui c'est une position une
partie qui pourrait
qui pourrait arriver ça je pense
de la tour pour le C5 je pense genre ça
et je pense que j'arrive ici à changer
un peu les pièces
ce petit pion qui était isolé je l'ai
changé
un petit peu c'est vrai
que c'était lui quand tu vois qu'il y a
un gain par exemple tu vois direct alors
que là moi ben je vois pas quand même
même vous non plus
et c'est Baptiste qui aiment bien la
vidéo alors oui j'ai fait ma vidéo je
suis passé ami le mois dernier je suis
passé maître international c'est tout
frais mon titre de maître
et donc la vidéo avec la dernière partie
que j'ai joué pour passer mettre et sur
Youtube donc pour ceux qui qui veulent
aller la voir je vous invite à visiter
ma page YouTube
et pour ceux qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui
surtout twitch ou sur Youtube pensez à
nous follow pour ceux qui nous follow
pas encore
c'est 5 min
j'ai plein de coups
mais ouais ça leur rapport embêtant
quand même pour pour Fabiano qui a un
petit peu B7
c'est un peu du voyez après je fais ça
je fais ça c'est un peu du bricolage
ça a l'air tendu quand même
assez petit
et du coup les
plans qui vont rester avec un peu plus
mais on est quand même
par exemple dame dessin qui a l'air
d'être un coup intéressant prise je
m'avais venir ici tu peux pas faire
tourner parce que je vais manger manger
et manger là donc c'est pas c'est clair
les dames C8
pour manger le fou derrière et le torcer
un pour empêcher ton C4 fou B7 et sur
casse danger vous voyez qu'il y a
beaucoup de contre jeux qui peut arriver
à tension au roi de Abdou qui pourrait
se faire mater là s'il faut bouge je
peux aussi faire ça je sais pas E5 et la
marche froid c'est plein d'idées pour
pour essayer de de
Fermat tout simplement donc un peu en
plus pour les blancs mais le bon contre
je et sur casse blanche ici peut-être un
jour faire F3 pour fermer tout ça et au
même F3 ça ouvre les quatre mois
maintenant ici et ça fait la structure
c'est pas sûr que ce soit aussi une
bonne idée on va voir un petit peu
comment ça se poursuit cette partie
je pensais à monter un pion des
ouais mais
j'arrivais jamais à pousser mes pions en
fait je trouvais qu'à chaque fois je
faisais plein de cases et plein de
contre jeux du coup j'avais beaucoup de
mal à
ah oui oui c'est clair je suis d'accord
il me semble
[Musique]
pas possible
il y a eu 27-3 Dame des 7 full attaque
la tour mesdames des 5 peut être un coup
alors dame de 5 est-ce que ça marche
il va faire froid probablement
il y a eu ton dessin OK
il va le faire tourner
mais sur le long terme ça peut être
embêtant
après si jamais les Noirs enfin les
blancs arrivent à changer les dames
sur le case blanche ça c'est un coup que
j'aime beaucoup de la part de Abdou
mais après à 4 on a quand même une
structure ou les blancs de plus mais le
pion BEP faible et photos l'opposé
encore une fois c'est pas sûr que ça
soit regardé 5 tu as qu'à deux
suffit de tomber vite vous voyez il y a
des caoutch je peux manger la viande
donc je suis pas sûr du tout que les
blancs soient beaucoup mieux là j'ai un
peu plus
mais il faut trouver les solutions parce
que même là si tu fais A3 et pas mon
pion en fait et ben il domine
complètement ta structure le 5 va être
chaud pour moi c'est évident
non je le mange le pion
qui est moche
et à 3 j'ai foulée trois aussi
ça va être je pense
les coups qui vont arriver je pense que
les blancs sont pas mieux c'est parti je
pense limite c'est les noirs qui peuvent
peut-être
s'il est blanche pas précis essaie
d'avoir un petit truc c'est pas
à trois du coup pour les blancs mais
ouais mais du coup tu me donnes toutes
les cases blanches
dur à 3
là
elle va plus vite hein mais c'est vrai
que enfin
à moins de 10 secondes attention c'est
pour ça que je suis là commence à être
chaud ici pour
pour
les blancs qui ont seulement 8 secondes
à la pendule pour B8 qui a un problème
sur le je vous avais dit que ça peut
vite très très vite se retourner cette
histoire
que je prends en deux j'attaque là et là
OK
mais bon ok 5 voilà voilà je monte le
roi toujours un peu plus facile à jouer
pour le noir
très peu
même si je suis pas sûr que ça va gagner
mais il y a quand même une petite
pression
en tout cas
alors d'où ce qu'un mec qui nous décrite
depuis YouTube j'ai mis du temps à
passer ma formation je suis j'ai
commencé enfin j'ai commencé un jeu
quand j'avais 6 ans
[Musique]
mais on va dire que
ça fait au moins depuis 2015 2016
que je lutte pour vraiment être
international
et
j'avais déjà les normes etc il manquait
plus que le point et l'eau
donc voilà bon je peux manger manger et
je prends ça c'est nul tous les jours si
je fais ça une très facilement
avec un fou qui peut arriver un jour
ok foulard
quand même
c'est un peu important
F4 découverte peut-être fou ici on
croise
dans tous les cas
pas évident
on parle de quel jeu
on parle de quel jeu là
on va passer par là
OK
il va il va nulle part ça peut être
chaud
et tout là
échec
attention que le tournoi ça peut être
une grosse menace moi je me lance
et plus de temps attendu la tension
il a complètement craqué notre ami Fabi
complètement craqué en l'option hache
qui passe et c'est gagner pour
incroyable c'est parti incroyable
Fabi qui qui poussait et finalement avec
le pion H qui est passé là et ben les
blancs qui ont réussi à transformer
alors que je pense qu'ils étaient même
en difficulté
à le cadre c'est hyper connu ça qu'on
échange tout
tomber a été joué
intéressant que souvent avec trois par
exemple à la place et des fous B4 il
faut prendre des deux et petits rock
très vite pour les noirs et du coup ici
avec avec ton bain en premier et ben ça
empêcher fou B4 peut-être tu vas le
faire maintenant
à 5 c'est un cool logique au final parce
que ça bloque un peu la colonne B qui
était prise par les blancs de base
donc à 5 a été joué
où est-ce qu'on joue avec événement avec
les Blancs
centrale avec des cinq possibles mais
attention qu'un jour après de dessin
de fou qui pourra sortir donc l'avantage
de garder le pion aussi les Noirs c'est
que le fou plus pas sortir franchement
je fais les 5 j'aide aussi un petit peu
les Noirs donc je suis pas sûr que le
dessin que ça soit vraiment le
l'objectif des blancs là peut-être que
oui mais on va voir que là il est pas
pressé en tout cas sa vie de jeu des
cinq
et on arrive bien à comprendre pourquoi
donc H3 était joué H3 c'est aussi un
coup qui empêche
éventuellement un futur fougère
qui me laisse une carte pour mon Roi au
cas où vous savez la petite fenêtre
qu'on recommande tout le temps pour
éviter le match du couloir et donc c'est
important de pouvoir essayer de jouer
des coups comme ça un petit peu
préventif un peu à l'avance donc vous
êtes avec les jouets comment est-ce que
je continue avec les Blancs
je suis pas fan de dessin pour les
raisons évoquées avant
mais comment on peut continuer si on
joue pas foudre
à ça on est quand même prêt à toutes les
pièces qui m'a bien placé et un moment
donné il va descendre
donc les cinq presque 3 mètres
et maintenant il faut récupérer ce petit
pion en dessin
tour à 3 actif menace souffrant H3
regarder prise
et tu reprends F3 comment c'est malin ou
inversement pour prendre et essayer de
mater donc avoir un peu comment ça se
passe donc c'est quand même du jeu du
côté des Noirs voir s'il y en a assez
peut-être dans mes F4 peut être un coup
d'un point F4 tours F4 je perds à deux
mais peut-être qu'après je peux pousser
ce petit pion des je suis pas sûr que ce
soit bon de contrôle comme ça je cherche
des idées
Mb4 tu me prends tu prends
et après je passe
en mangeant
3 ça devait être aussi un coup qui peut
être intéressant et dame de 4 c'est du
coup que je proposais
donc pour moi d'en prendre quasi une
quasi forcé même si je peux encore faire
ça peut-être
c'est la partie non c'est pas la partie
parce que là maintenant ça défend et si
tu prends là je prends la
il a mangé des 4 ce que j'aime pas parce
que maintenant quand tu prends
tu es moins possible je pense de l'autre
côté
je pousse le pion et j'ai quand même
l'impression que les Blancs poussent un
peu à manger
6 et ça a l'air chaud
regardez c'est la partie ou pas
et j'arrive peut-être
vous voyez à manger
après ça reste compliqué même cette
position et peut-être nulle
que j'ai raté au début
[Musique]
qui contrôle aussi la case
et qui menace ton premier set comment
est-ce qu'on joue ici
comment vas-tu
j'ai pas envie de jouer parce que mon
royaume est ouvert vous imaginez après
un truc comme ça
alors ça marcherait pas là mais un jour
si je bouge mon fou déjà il va passer ma
tour ça peut faire très mal sur le pion
G2 c'est pas trop une bougie les pions
l'option F
si bouge le cavalier après il a des
idées pour attaquer
comme par exemple tout à l'heure je
pense que ça reste une idée intéressante
pour les Noirs dans quelques
6 parce que je prends et il y a peu en
prise
donc pas évidente 5
ça peut être jouable
pas clair cette pause
qui me fait peur
il y a eu fou F5 et 5 de jouer
qui est j'arrive à manger
ouf beaucoup mais après là ça reste du
Blitz ça
bien sûr que c'est plus un instant quoi
donc il y a des calculs bien entendu
mais plus ça va vite plus c'est de
l'instinct c'est le calcul c'est pas le
calcul brut quoi c'est plus
donc qui est tourné 6 pour bloquer
pas mal pour manger le pion
là ok je peux toujours pousser je sais
pas trop ce que ça peut être
tu manges là je mange là ok bon on
échange les tours
et je m'en vais passer toujours il va
pousser il a pas le choix
monter le roi
peut-être que ça peut un peu
et après le 5
faire gaffe quand même
dangereux
[Musique]
des 6 et 6 peut-être
est-ce cavalier qui va qui va se cacher
ton bien avec tes jouets
en fait si jamais on arrive si les Noirs
arrivent à manger le pion dessin voilà
c'est parti
[Musique]
ils vont vous proposer et ça a balancé
voilà ça a proposé ça fait une direct
donc belle défense en tout cas de Abdou
qui était pas très bien dans cette
partie
de 1 1 0 enfin toujours en faveur de de
Abdou qui a pas encore perdu de sortie
c'est la troisième partie il y a eu deux
nulle et une victoire pour pour Abdou
donc pour l'instant le match qui tombe
pas mal pour pour le joueur ouzbek donc
moi je l'avais dit par rapport aux
pronostics envoyé je vous avais dit que
je préférais
enfin que je donnais en tout cas
l'avantage au joueur ouzbeker
[Musique]
j'ai complètement apprécié en dessous je
pense que ça change pas trop mais il est
vrai que je dois mettre le score un jour
et là
et c'est fait
donc 2 1 pour l'instant pour le joueur
rouge bug
noire
et donc ton baby B5 c'est l'idée donc le
fou qui pouvait manger la tour si on
fait des sac avant donc on se déglue
vis-à-vis de la tour et on va je baisse
encore je sais pas de suite ou si
ou si
il va préparer ça des cinq alors quand
même pas mal du tout ici ouais c'est la
partie
donc ce pion on voit la garder alors
c'est Carole arrive
mais en échange et ben c'est vrai que
les Blancs ont plus d'espace et la
colonne vertes la colonne D qui est
assez forte ici et j'ai un peu du mal
avec les noirs a vraiment m'organiser
pour sortir la pièce donc on peut
imaginer un faux projet de la main et
cavalibou etc ça peut être un bon plan
pour le noir pour sortir de la pièce tu
as ma 4
tu parles tu parles d'avant avant avant
dans ma cadre c'est peut-être ici plutôt
et dans ma 4 je sais pas ce qui ont été
peut-être à 6
suivi de cavaliers c'est 5 peut-être que
chasse
et je fais des 5
peut-être c'est une possibilité
après je peux aussi faire comme
ça mais ce puits
avec les Noirs c'est pour ça que même
assis c'était possible aussi
je pense parce que ça pion en
généralement on s'accroche pas tout le
temps
a été joué
et salut à la Dino
C5 peut être joué aussi sûrement mais
attention que c'est 5 ça donne des cases
quand même
un jour qui peut être une cible sympa
pour les pour les blancs
donc
les pions faire attention ne pas trop
trop les avancer non plus parce que vous
savez plus avancépion plus je donne des
cases à mes adversaires et un pion c'est
bête ce que je veux dire mais un pion
c'est un recul pas
ça recule pas et bah avant de les jouer
soyez sûr de vous
parce que sinon c'est la cata
[Musique]
tout le monde en même temps
et maintenant voir comment est-ce que je
continue moi j'aimais bien ce petit coup
il y en a deux un je pense qu'il a pas
longtemps
moi j'aime bien les Noirs parce que oui
c'est une position où les Noirs ont une
majorité ce côté-là
et sur le long terme pousser les pions
alors que les Blancs jouent plus pour
leur majorité aller droit donc avec
attaque sur le roi ici mais la taxe sur
l'Europe pour l'instant la gamme assez
difficile à faire
et si je bouge mon cahier juste je peux
aussi faire ça d'ailleurs
ça c'est
possible et si je bouge mon cavalier
qui s'échangent c'est la partie et c'est
la partie incroyable incroyable
Tim judo
[Musique]
qui a emprise donc peut-être faire
qu'avec G6 fubou
et
c'est moche donc
les blancs toujours un peu mieux par
rapport à structure tiens pas peur du
pion B2 si je prends mes deux il y a
échec tu reprends échec cavailler le
cavalier
donc je ne peux pas faire ça maintenant
que je défends le mat peut-être à 6
pour sortir par là compliqué pas simple
et comme du jeu voyageur il trouve
jamais ils vont jamais défendre un pion
passivement en fait les meilleurs
joueurs du monde ils vont toujours
essayer de prendre l'initiative dans
toutes les positions et je trouve ça
beau en fait
c'est pas très dur à voir mais dans
l'idée que vraiment c'est vraiment à
chaque fois quand tu as le choix entre
défendre la pièce ou faire une menace
plus forte que c'est ton adversaire et
bien ils vont toujours choisir le coup
qui fait une glace plus forte que celle
de l'adversaire parce que c'est un coup
qui va gagner l'initiative donc je
trouve que c'est vraiment
de beaux exemples ce qu'on a ici
tout simplement c'est qu'en fait après
ça ça je vais essayer de faire ça
ramener le tour
et là il y a presque donc faire H5
d'avoir cavalier
un thème pour être intéressant en tout
cas
c'est pas mal j'aime bien ce genre de
coup F3
salut à toi
ça me fait halluciner comment pour toi
c'est tellement simple
ouais bon après je me trompe tout le
temps je me trompe souvent quand même
parce que bon le niveau en face c'est
quand même les meilleurs joueurs du
monde donc bon bah si je devine tout
c'est peut-être que moi aussi je suis
champion du monde mais malheureusement
je ne suis pas jambon du monde donc je
devine pas tout mais c'est vrai qu'en
fait tout ce qu'ils font c'est assez
logique au final c'est assez logique
[Musique]
depuis qu'il y a eu ça et là maintenant
comment je fais pour jouer contre ce
cavalier Roy
F24 éventuel pour un cavalier alors ici
je sais même pas mais regardez imaginons
on fait ça mais je prends ici en fait
donc vous voyez que mettre le cavalier
en décape ça va être l'idée des Noirs
voilà mais le fait de garder le pur en
E2 ça me donne l'option un jour pour
faire autrement je trouve ça cool ce que
fait ici Abdou ne pas jouer le 4 vous
voyez pas trop pousser les pions quand
c'est pas nécessaire
on cherche vraiment à la stabilité pour
ce cavalier j'ai quand même bien G4
petit coup pour prendre un petit peu les
cases blanches de ce côté là
attention à cette casse quand même
qui me fait un peu peur
mais c'est vrai qu'après je peux
toujours faire pousser trois pour me
replacer à la défense de plan B2
solidement ces trois étaient joués
donc prise cavalier prend pour
aller prendre ah j'ai pas torse de
tactique là rapidement si prise qu'elle
va l'écran tours
[Musique]
une découverte de l'autre côté donc pour
cela a été joué et plus que 15 secondes
chacun attention c'est hyper compliqué
si je prends là tu prends ici je prends
là tu prends là c'est c'est un bouftou
qui peut arriver de Tours C6 à l'air
logique
je bloque enfin je bouge mon cavalier
avec un bateau
j'ai l'impression que tout va s’échanger
maintenant tourbé 7
fullafula je mets bien le fou qui
pouvait venir et là-bas je pense que ça
va s'échanger et ça va faire nul très
probablement maintenant tour de 5 le fou
quand même en E3 je pense ça casse pour
faire ça vous voyez un petit fou en E3
et une tour là ça peut manger un petit
peu un jour
et maintenant ça peut répéter ça on
décide
je pars recette donc le roi qui avait
des bêtises
et Abdou qui vient de perdre un pion là
ça peut être le tournant du 7 hein
on va manger ce cavalier il veut pas
bien entendu H4
[Musique]
il faut 300
j'aime bien ça bloque tout il faut tous
mes coups et c'est bloqué maintenant et
puis ça bouge plus
ou c'est 5 toujours
le 4 et maintenant le pion tout qui va
tomber j'ai l'impression prise
il y a un pion plus toujours hein ça
joue encore
plus c'est pas clair pour chaque voilà
bouger
cette position
[Musique]
j'ai 6 c'était je peux pas bouger une
pièce en fait
si je bouge le cavale je perds
[Musique]
cavalier qui va peut-être s'activer un
peu il y a trois secondes chacun
je pense que
c'est une erreur
franchement les joueurs sont juste
monstrueux et enfin ça va tellement vite
qu'en fait juste bon les commentaires
sont impossible mais les gens en trois
secondes à la fin avec une minute pardon
3 secondes à la pendule et une seconde
parcours c'est juste ça va très très
très vite ok donc je vais ajuster le
score pour ce match donc on est à 2 et
demi à 1 et demi pour le genre rose bec
UPS à la mi-parcours donc je vous
rappelle qu'on a F on avait pris des
paris pour le score du celte et on avait
dit que on avait dit que enfin je pense
que vous hein au Paris vous aviez
surtout parier sur carweba et pour
l'instant Cabana et ben il est il est
mené d'un point après ça va rien dire
sympa extrêmement
serré mais mais ça va se jouer
très très vite donc enfin une petite
pause de 5 minutes
avant la reprise donc on a après 43
minutes de 5 + 1 2 nouveau avec la sauce
score de et demi 1 et demi pour je vous
dis à tout de suite
vous les streamer des échecs comme vous
créateurs préférés tels que bin stream
Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/settings/connecting
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans notre
liste de streamers en direct votre
profites.com affichera votre stream
twitch qui sera aussi mis en avant
durant vos parties enfin utiliser la
commande community streamer dans le chat
faites grossir votre audience sans plus
attendre
[Musique]
je suis de retour
pour cette suite de match du premier set
alors que la partie va commencer on voit
le compteur qui a été lancé mais c'est
moi la partie n'a pas réparée
C4 jouer par Fabi avec les Blancs
donc une anglaise
E3 comme tout à l'heure il avait Jacques
B3 fois
il y avait eu ça
a changé est-ce que
aurait pas vérifié ses lignes rapidement
pendant la pause puisque tout à l'heure
il a pas du tout jouer ça ce coup d'un
A5
généralement est extrêmement préparé
dans les ouvertures en tout cas c'est un
joueur qui sera pas beaucoup
donc
dans ces format là en plus il est Triki
il va vite je pense que c'est vraiment
un avoir c'est redoutable Abdou et je
pense franchement qu'il peut venir à
bout de de carmena et moi d'ailleurs je
vous avais dit je vais me favoris
moi je vais favoris Abdou dans ce match
il m'a l'air d'être
meilleur dans cette dans ce format là
alors
un peu les pièces et affaiblir un peu le
roi sur quasiment peut-être c'est
possible
il y a d'autres coups qui sont aussi
possible les dames c'est deux qui peut
être joué pour s'envoyer vis-à-vis là
défendre le fou préparer B5 il y a plein
de coups possible pour les pour les
blancs ici
ils affichent une cinquième gagnée
partie
oui en fait ce qui s'est passé je pense
si elle veut
c'est qu'en fait ils ont commencé la
partie les joueurs mais tes 4 jours une
pause entre chaque
milieu de portion et du coup annuler la
partie et pour annuler parce qu'ils ont
fait mais voilà mais en tout cas la
partie King Kong pas je pense donc voilà
salut à toi Cyril 59 bienvenue sur le
stream tour c'est un jouet Dame des 7
voyez un tour C1 dès qu'il y a des
vis-à-vis généralement les joueurs de ce
niveau là il reste pas en face donc là
moi j'aurais bien comme deux ou dame C2
pour aussi partir de ce vis-à-vis de ce
qui me dérange un petit peu quand même
donc j'aime bien il y avait prise des
cartes sûrement alors
cavalier prend ou plus on prend
maintenant
des quatre avec l'idée de fermer un peu
la position et de créer un pion isolé
chez les Noirs il y a eu cavalier à 4
échanger
les fois en B2 il y a ces options en
prise peut-être que maintenant mais
maintenant T4 à la fin je perdrai et
puis on a trois donc c'est pas une bonne
une bonne affaire
d'un c2b6 était 4 je peux toujours
manger toujours sans prise ce pion à 3
c'est c'est un problème alors cette
position c'est un problème qui qui fait
que j'ai du mal vraiment
à jouer au centre
alors je sais pas si les Noirs veulent
au-dessus des quatre ça pourrait être
une possibilité pour rentrer le pion
d'y aller tout simplement je veux bien
la position de noir ici
je trouve que en pratique c'est plus
facile à jouer
car il est 3 alors là il est à Sega qui
peut être avec l'idée en fait de toutes
les changer manger ici et faire des
pions passer ici il y a pas eu ça il y a
eu B6 pour défendre
et maintenant ce que manger des quatre
c'est un peu chaud quand même
oui ça ouvre vraiment le truc classe
blanche donc ça a l'air chelou mais
peut-être nécessaire parce que si je
joue pas des cartes les blancs qui vont
faire des quatre il y a vraiment un
bloqué ce pion isolé ou depuis en tout
cas en dessin qu'il y a toujours prises
ça il y a toujours cette même question
sur le pion à 3 qui peut être un souci
pour être une très bonne idée défendre
ici vous dire trois café noir je
rapprocher un peu et c'est bon
c'est long tout ça comment est-ce qu'on
joue avec les noirs
moi j'avais bien Descartes mais
Descartes ça va pas être bon
notre punissable probablement
des quatre je pensais c'est pas croire
et de prendre de l'espace mais bon j'ai
un peu peur du vis-à-vis là et il faut
assiste qui a l'air très malin en fait
qui
attaque la Tour Eiffel et surtout
peut-être maintenant des cadres et
essayer vraiment de de bloquer un petit
peu ces cases là ça a l'air pas mal du
tout pour noir
et on voit sa vie qui réfléchit est-ce
qu'il pense à ne pas bouger la tour ça
sera c'est incroyable
des trois peut-être
ton plan un jour
et ben c'est bizarre sur le froid
après Détroit il peut y avoir
ici si je mange là tu peux manger là
[Musique]
ça peut être compliqué je sais pas
ce qu'il est possible de faire il y a eu
tout droit
essayer de passer
comme ça et attaquer un petit peu le roi
noir
ma mère
on va manger le pion G6 on va ramener le
cavalier on va ramener la dame et
vraiment on va mettre toutes les pièces
sur
le roi noir c'est un plan intéressant
petit coup H4 là et un bout qui
réfléchit donc là avec une minute
d'avance à la pendule dans cette
position qui est un peu tricky
est-ce que carvana va réussir à égaliser
dans ce match j'aime beaucoup le coup
des quatre encore tout à l'heure il y a
toujours ça qui arrive mais dame là ça
serait vraiment génial
malheureusement la dame ne va pas dans
le cavalier si je pouvais tomber un coup
je vous garantis qu'il le jouer
j'ai peur aussi de mettre en vis-à-vis
de la tour même si c'est pour un seul ou
un baiser c'est un peu long pas sûr que
ce soit ce qui va faire donc T3
et ce qui joue
il se développe un peu et il prend du
temps
maintenant sur des cas je vais voir 4
pour bloquer un peu la pose
d'un mec 6 que d'un B2 c'est un coup
ça la risquait mais en fait ce pion
si tu pousses un jour à 4 tu as toujours
une canne avec 4 donc après dans B2 il
faudrait
qui est pas forcément l'idée des
blancs de base donc un des deux avec les
jeux c'est logique
et maintenant comment est-ce que je
continue la partie c'est compliqué comme
position
de compliquer et à nous qui est pas qui
est pas content
il est pas content
un truc maintenant qu'il arrive des deux
et ben je pense que le DK va être une
menace parce qu'il y a plus d'enfants à
trois
structure ou il y a un gros pion en
dessin qui est une grosse faiblesse
donc c'était pas forcément un très bon
coup de la part d'Abdou qui a permis ce
D4 de famille donc avec une minute 20
d'avance
je pense que famille est pas mal parti
pour prendre l'avantage d'un B2 alors
logique en ce moment vis-à-vis on me
défend le pion ici peut-être un jour
pour un jeu B4 avoir
peut-être C4 qui peut toutes s'échanger
dame B2
alors
bon je vais cadre tu n'auras pas de la
reprise ok jouer
peut-être faire un P4 ça l'air un peu
bizarre mais je pense qu'il faut je vais
ça fait quand même deux fois je pense
que vous voyez ça fait deux fois que
Fabi
joue B4 que je suis avec lui pour je
mets 4 et que l'ordinateur à chaque fois
il dit que c'est un mauvais coup c'est
incroyable
P4 c'est bien compris c'est vraiment un
coup qu'il faut que j'arrête de jouer
donc cavaliers à 5 on revient en B3 plus
tard avec le cavalier noir mais le
caverne B3 il est pas forcément c'est
bien placé que ça en fait au final moi
je vais faire ma vie avec mes pièces
donc avaler il fera pas grand chose ici
il y a plus beau que bon
fou c'est eux qui a été joué qu'est-ce
qu'on joue avec les Blancs faut que je
le vide pour garder longtemps
je vais vite pour garder le temps à
4,6 et les noirs qui vont essayer de
améliorer les pièces moi je vais mettre
un cavalier F5 qui a validé 6 paf paf
pour viser un peu le casque comme un
casse de 4 d'un P4 réalité joué
cavalier 6 à 5 et là une prise un tour
un tour à trois rentrer quelques tours
ça peut être pas mal pour les blancs
et à nous qui est
qui est pas content de ce qu'il fait là
pas content du tout
[Musique]
il a été hyper passif il y avait deux
une pièce en un coup ça va être abandon
c'est incroyable bon c'est incroyable
voyez à ce niveau-là ça oblige des
pièces en un coup
ça oui des pièces
alors qu'on est au début du match
voilà là c'est quand même
gratuit ça fait ça fait une heure qui
joue je veux bien mais une heure c'est
pas énorme sur un masque qui va en durer
trois ça commence comme ça rater des
pièces sans un coup
après les blancs restent mieux quand
même c'est une belle rencontre
de belles pièces mais bon
[Musique]
bien c'est une pièce quand même
j'ai 4
qui va rentrer à la maison
emprise
de plus pour qu'elle prend aussi mais
fin la partie tu manges là je mange là
au revoir ok bon c'est quand même une
partie méritée de la part de carvalin
mais une pièce en un coup a été a été
raté
et ça c'est incroyable à ce niveau là
après ça peut arriver on va rendre les
joueurs qui sont humains
les gens sont humains ça arrive on
dirait moi qui joue c'est clair on
dirait moi aussi
et allez ça peut se on a déjà eu tout à
l'heure il y avait eu à 5 tours et avec
le tour des 8 il me semble même partie
tout à l'heure
et surtout on débute on avait eu
un point c'est 4 x 6 car elle va aller
prendre des 5 tours des cinq et dames 6
avec Dame D8
dame C8
ce match
Mb4 va venir défendre un petit peu le
pion c'est 4 on menace on échange de
pièces
[Musique]
voilà je me masque
numéro 1
tu prends je prends la dame et sur
quelle réponse
là soit je fais d'abord car elle prend
le 2 intermédiaire et je mange
la dame en tout cas
la grosse nasse c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici du coup
dame ces deux mais c'est un peu la loose
non je prends là je prends large madame
à trois avec les jouets
c'est quand même plus en fait
je pense pas qu'il y ait de plus
convaincant ou pas plus convaincant à ce
niveau-là ils sont en blitz le but c'est
de gagner la partie donc tu manges la
pièce et c'est suffisant ce matériel
sauf si c'est mal de partout je
comprends mais là pour le coup non mais
juste il a pas vu ça arrive d'oublier
des choses ça arrive même pour la
meilleure heure du monde ça arrive
ils sont humains
en tout cas le fait de rater des pièces
nous ça nous rassure un peu
ça nous rassure un peu de voir à quel
point les joueurs sont capables aussi de
faire la même bêtise que nous on fait
tous les jours donc elle va répondre à 5
attaque là je comprends bien
ma souris et on prend des quatre
est-ce que ça va se jouer comme ça comme
c'est simple je peux manger
la structure serait complètement oui
néanmoins
je pense que
[Musique]
un gain de pièces en un coup qui n'a pas
été fait et quand la dame qui n'a pas
été mangé le joueur qui a oublié quoi
qui a zappé oui la partie d'avant
le cavalier la bougie la tour il y avait
de la prend cavalier mais
caréna il a pas mangé cavalier il a
d'autres choses et du coup il a défendu
cavalier Abdou
c'est un oubli donc cette fois a été
joué il y a ici F4 arrivé mais
bonjour Messi
mais si
il faut F4 si je mange de juste enfin je
bouffe la bouffe là je bouffe là je
bouffe là
pour défendre sa petite fion de
et sur votre roche c'est pas trop
c'est un encore une fois je vous
rappelle tous les joueurs qui jouent
tout le temps l'initiative à fond à
chaque fois c'est pareil c'est au lieu
de défendre les pions ils vont toujours
essayer d'attaquer les pions adverse
c'est toujours comme ça toujours comme
ça
mais bon ok ça reste solide pour les
pour les Noirs
pas forcément évident et tout aussi on
va défendre quand même ici et comme tout
à l'heure en fait
les blancs qui qui ont une position qui
est quand même assez agréable sur la
colonne c'est etc mais il en manque le
fou le casque blanche devant endroit
donc
éventuellement un jour peut-être qu'un
peut-être qu'on pourra ramener la dame
ramener le fou sur case blanche vous
voyez et avoir un truc mais pour
l'instant c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à
voir comment
mais ça risque d'arriver dans 30 on
reprend
et la prise en E2 comment on la voit
ça a l'air débile c'est la partie
c'est la partie
si je fais ça
bah je m'en fous
j'ai l'impression que ce pion il était
après il y a toujours ce problème sur le
site sur un problème ça
donc c'est pas
peut-être pas si grave que ça mais bon
écoute
c'est un pion
un pion c'est un pion et Fabi qui mange
les viandes tout simplement
ça peut ça peut arriver aussi
franchement
savoir mais c'est vrai que
pas si clair cette histoire
A4 je pensais vraiment
[Musique]
comment est-ce que je passe avec mes
pièces avec le tour à 6
ce qui est relativement moche surtout
raciste avec tour B6 mais j'aurais
toujours à 5 toujours en l'air
c'est clair qu'il y a une pression il y
a une pression côté blanc quand même
avec les deux qui peut arriver avec ton
5 qui peut arriver et puis
mon four a dû mal à revenir en défense
surtout c'est toujours fou c'est calme
peut-être
pour essayer de
déconnecter un peu les tours
mais c'est vrai que des deux le pion est
perdu
façon et tout ça mais j'ai fou ces
quatre peut-être
on va manger on va manger ici
donc avec les jouets
on parle russe sur Youtube je ne parle
pas réussi je ne sais pas ce qui a été
dit
on parle beaucoup de langues mais
celle-là
pour que je te dise
attention ça peut être chaud
mais ça a l'air attend attend du gamin
complications
à 5 alors comment être fou prend un sac
c'est la partie ou F3 je mange une fois
juste et
mon roi est toujours un peu en réseau ça
a toujours un peu embêtant et je pense
j'arrive m'en sortir avec H3
c'est-à-dire que je fais ça je pense à
faire ça donc
moi
un truc comme ça par exemple vous voyez
que c'est pas celui-là
ça peut arriver quoi
c'est pas facile pour moi de m'enlever
des échecs
je sens qu'il a été joué
qui va quand même pousser il va être
avancé
il va être avancé
moi j'ai 7
il a les pions qui vont avancer c'est
moi qui l'a joué ça il vient pas trop
après à 5 il a plus la plus le casque
pour le fou donc pour C3 imaginer un
plan avec
l'archite pas échanger une tour
qui évitera un peu le mât du couloir
et après c'est un jour P5 cette tour là
c'est pas débile on va c'est la partie
son idée prise du Fou pro probablement
du roi pour le roy F2 mais bon ok le fou
qui bouge donc elle est par là
ça donne des cases tout ce qu'il a fait
il a un pion de plus mais donne des
cases
et 6 secondes c'est très très peu
c'est vraiment très très peu des cinq tu
arrives pas à le faire pour l'instant à
5 j'arrive toujours à bloquer
donc pour l'instant
et chaque peut-être et on ramène le roi
c'est chaud voilà c'est ma tête là
écoutez je commence à préférer les noirs
c'est officiel je préfère largement la
position
la position de famille
autant incroyable un peu qui perd autant
ça fait deux fois d'affilée
qu'il perd autant
notre ami à Bruxelles
qui prend le lead
dans ce match ça va reprendre ici
quelques instants pourquoi les joueurs
ne reprennent pas
parce que moi je vois pas la partie là
vous allez voir un mini break de
quelques secondes
alors un lag oui ça peut ça peut arriver
ça c'est
le lac ça peut arriver encore une fois
[Musique]
ça dépend de la connexion de chacun et
tout mais
pas pas évident
pas évident
ok donc là ça joue un petit système de
Londres
il reste 18 minutes dans ce temps
réglementaire de 5 + 1 donc on a cette
partie là et après sur moi encore encore
une autre donc encore deux parties en 5
+ 1 avant d'enchaîner avec le 3 + 1 donc
ça dépend
comment on joue qu'après des fois aussi
alors comment il va jouer ici
à
parce que la prise est fout des trois
cama c'est logique
et fou je crois aussi un bon coup
surprise h30
que ma tour sur le roi adverse donc
c'est un peu l'idée
fous des trois petits rock
et avoir un peu comment ça se passe
donc là
c'est aussi un cookie pour plus tard
être joué
les foodcasses blanches mais les Noirs
ont toujours attendre que des fous
bougent le fou enfin les blancs bougent
le font avant de le couper 5
pour ça que s'en fout des trois et en
fait prise
peut-être c'est chaud
tactiquement faut voir ce qui se passe
on s'en fout prend là je prends un temps
de me dire avoir
ici Abdou avec
avec les noirs sur foudre
merci à toi FX
alors j'ai appris des choses sur toi
c'est il y a pas longtemps j'étais pas
au courant
de plein de choses
plein de choses sur toi
mais on en reparlera bientôt je
t'écrirai je t'écrirai bientôt
et oui Faby j'imagine bien c'est clair
tu serais pas venu pour le match
d'arrognan d'ailleurs c'était pas vu je
t'ai pas vu la semaine dernière pour
arrogant
c'est pas le joueur que tu préfères et
pourtant moi je l'aime bien à rognan on
a deux discussions plusieurs fois
[Musique]
donc faut H4 a été joué et là comment
est-ce que je défends ce qu'il y avait
leur cavaliers
manger le cavalier et là soit je laisse
soit je joue au 7 c'est un peu bizarre
je fouette
des fois on peut très bien sortir des
pièces justes et laisser
et en fait il sait dire que j'ai la part
de fou et les quasiment avec les Noirs
j'aimerais ouvrir mais j'ai les cases
noires donc un très récent avoir 5 pour
tuer un petit peu le case blanche et
plus tard mettre le four à M6 ou en G7
et défendre un peu la position avoir un
peu ce que apprendre comme décision a
ici à vous c'est pas évident parce que
pour laisser quand même
le roi ouvert il faut en avoir c'est pas
si évident comme décision à prendre
est-ce qu'il va faire rapidement
favoriser notre
je sais pas en fait si tu veux
plein de tournois on l'a vu dans toutes
les cadences tiens d'ailleurs on l'a vu
jouer les production Manchester etc mais
toutes les cadences là enfin tous ces
tournages c'est des cadences de 15 + 5
ou un truc comme ça 15 + 3 et tout ce
qui est vraiment Blitz sur Internet on
n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup vu
donc je suis pas sûr je sais pas trop
mais c'est vrai qu'en toutes les parties
contre famille j'ai l'impression qu'il
est un peu mal au temps à chaque partie
il a moins bien autant après en Bullet
on va voir il joue quand même
extrêmement bien il a de l'agilité ça
c'est clair mais
je trouve que
en tout cas dans les parties qui jouent
là il est très souvent moi bien autant
il a souvent une huile de moi ou un truc
comme ça donc si
[Musique]
ils sont pas le plus vite dans le parti
de 3 + 1 ou 1 + 1 il va y avoir du mal
il va avoir du mal
mais non le match il est hyper close
hein pour moi je pense que c'est c'est
match qui va se jouer à pas plus de deux
points
ça va être très compliqué là je pense à
bien aimer les Noirs parce que du coup
regardez il a juste ce que j'avais dit
il a fait je vais prendre FC il a fait
F5 et du coup on va regarder le foutage
c'est du mal à jouer et en plus j'ai la
part de fou avec les Noirs donc
ça a l'air pas mal
donc
on peut y voir à plus tard un F3 F3 E4
pour ouvrir un peu la position pour
ouvrir le fou quoi mais c'est vrai que
la position qui va s'ouvrir va forcément
mettre en valeur les pièces blanches en
fait là en face j'ai les Noirs j'attends
que faire tout en dessous de la part de
fou
quand vous avez des fous de manière
générale c'est à vous d'ouvrir la
position donc F3 E4 m'a l'air assez
osé quand même mais là c'est pour chacun
des deux familles il y a une pollution
qui est vraiment difficile à jouer pour
un cavalier le 7 qui avait G6 avec
l'attaque qui peut arriver rapidement
j'aime beaucoup la potion la position
adaptée
donc plus grand chose ouais ouais
cette position elle est elle est dure
pour pour les blancs mais en fait ce qui
est marrant c'est qu'en fait à chaque
fois on pense plein de parties depuis le
début on a l'impression que
que
même quand tu es très rare Emmanuel
joueur eux
ils trouvent toujours
des moyens de jouer donc c'est hyper
intéressant et très pédagogique de
suivre un joueur comme ça et de regarder
les moments où il est foutu de voir
comment eux ils jouent parce qu'en fait
il voit toujours des occases ou des
choses pour pour
avoir du jeu c'est assez incroyable donc
là je me demande bien comment il va
faire
carvana pour essayer de prendre
l'avantage il a laissé la
ou pas j'ai toujours perdu quand même
intéressant aussi
pour empêcher cette intrusion ici
mais c'est cool de voir des gens comme
ça je veux sur deux rangées pour voir un
peu comment eux réagissent quand ils
sont mal quoi c'est encore une fois les
joueurs sont hyper fort mais c'est pas
des ordinateurs c'est pas des machines
on a vu on a on a eu fallu tout à
l'heure famille qui a pas vu une pièce
en un coup quoi
il y a une pire qui était lâchée en
prise il a pas mangé la pièce quoi les
deux ont raté la pièce
[Musique]
et donc ça montre bien que c'est des
humains quoi et
[Musique]
donc avoir mais en tout cas c'est clair
que là j'aime beaucoup la potion noir
et je sais pas comment je continue avec
les Blancs qui avaient les quatre ok
tourbe vite
ça floue légendaire
les quatre peut-être la prise en C4
ouais il y a une toux qui s'ouvrait
mais généralement même s'il y a tout qui
s'ouvre tu perds un pion dans l'histoire
c'est pas si grave ça dépend des
positions de trucs mais là c'est la part
de fou avec les Noirs donc c'est la
position s'ouvre au centre généralement
ça va partager le genre qu'elle a par
défaut
donc avoir mais le B4 avait l'air hyper
intéressant en effet
qui roi de 7 je pensais baisser 3 en C4
ah oui mais il peut la tenir il peut
tout de même la gagner regardez au fur
et à mesure mais il sera pas grand chose
peut-être que c'est la manière parce
qu'en fait au final les noirs de fou etc
mais au final le fou en 17 c'est
mauvaise pièce Le qui avait des gaz
G4 regardez hop la pression qui
s'inverse un petit peu le ranger ce qui
est venu se promener un petit peu loin
peut-être
parce que j'ai trop à l'air un peu
optimiste j'ai foutran G3
d'un côté j'ai envie de le faire parce
que je me dis que c'est la seule bonne
pièce des Noirs donc c'est pas trop peur
de la prise ici d'un autre côté je
comprends que c'est qu'elle m'a dit
quand même il est important un contrôle
de gaz du roi donc j'ai pas envie de
changer la cavalière commence à menacer
des petits réseaux de maths
fousser 8 et Abdou qui commence un peu à
capituler dans ce match ça fait quand
même deux victoires d'affilée de Fabi et
avec
cette troisième défilé qui est qui vient
d'arriver sa vie qui qui est en train de
de démolir mentalement
Abdou Alex 3 à la suite
alors petite catalane chez Abdou
cette position qu'on a vu beaucoup dans
ma 4G 5 le petit rock à 5 tours
[Musique]
quand même c'était pas si clair et il y
a eu le tour des villes dans la première
partie il y a une MBK dans la deuxième
partie
et donc la troisième partie qu'est-ce
que Abdou qu'est-ce que ça dit
va décider de jouer dans celle-là et
c'est sûrement d'ailleurs la dernière
partie
du 7 il reste 7 minutes 45 autant
réglementaire pour ce 7 la cadence c'est
5 + 1 donc je pense que c'est la
dernière
partie de ce segment en 5 + 1 après on
aura encore une heure de trois piscines
et une demi-heure de business il a
vraiment il y a vraiment
du temps pour se refaire donc après
sécateur on avait des fous aussi c'est
la partie
je m'en souviens encore
comme dit c'était tout à l'heure donc
ça change
et
logique au final regardez tout ce qui se
passe là il y a un fou de gaz blanche
qui a pointé sur sur le roi qui n'a pas
de défenseur sur casse blanche et c'est
vraiment l'idée de la position les
Blancs ont un avantage de structure et
de envoyer il y a plus un 7 ça a 5 et 7
qui sont isolés et on peut mettre la
pression dessus etc mais en contrepartie
et ben j'ai aussi
j'ai aussi direct vu contre je
sur les pertes blanches donc c'est
extrêmement
intéressant ici
je préfère avoir les Noirs dans cette
position
parce que je trouve que le chrono sur 15
branche il est pas évident à négocier
et en blitz comme ça on préfère
clairement avoir le joueur qui a le plus
d'activités
et
donc la structurelle mauvaise pour le
blanc mais il y a un peu en plus
ton dessin
de ce pion
mais bon est-ce que ça va suffire
ok F6 c'est intéressant
bien sûr regardez bien ce qui se passe
là paire de feu foutu l'opposé donc on
va chacun mettre les pions sur la
couleur inverse du four pour restreindre
le champ des fous adverses
la fois E5 on va essayer de prendre les
cases du foie de verse et mettre tout
sur noir pour que mon fou sur case
blanche puisse
mal mes flèches mais vous avez compris
ce que je veux dire que mon fou soit
fort sur case blanche
de faire tandis que
Abdou bah il y a deux points de moins il
a des blancs
sur famille donc là je pense que ça
jouera
je pense que Fabi serait content de
faire vivre ici il y a deux points
d'avance et les Noirs mais après je
pense à quoi ça joue la partie
je veux la partie
mais après faut reposer c'est pas tout
le temps nul c'est une tendance à faire
nul quand on s'est fait un de roi et fou
mais là j'ai encore deux tours chacun
qui est encore quand même pas mal de
choses à faire
donc
non rien n'est joué là
non non
il a deux points de moi il est mené donc
vous inquiétez pas qu'il va pas faire
nul sans jeu comme ça et encore plus
avec les Blancs
encore plus avec les Blancs
c'est un joueur qui va
essayer de grind essayer de prendre
l'avantage
qui va bien sûr se refaire c'est un
joueur qui est extrêmement compatible
je voulais faire nul comme ça
les gens ils sont jeunes et pour
progresser j'ai pas du tout pour
faire des nuls rapides c'est pas du tout
dans son intention
troisième
structure le pion qui contrôle la tour
ici celui-là aussi le roi en C4 il va
être
un délogeable alors je crois c'est quand
elle tourne
et si je mange là puis on prend je
prends là et surtout reprend
la colonne
il faut manger je pense même si je mange
pas tu rentres comment si je prends là
puis on prend je prends là et surtout
reprend là tu as la colonne mais tu as
aucune casse pour rentrer donc à voir
avant c'est la partie la manger
peut-être je sais plus il est possible
sur Internet il est possible que j'ai
déjà joué
il est possible
je peux vous le dire pas vous le dire
avec mon vrai compte je suis pas sûr il
y a une petite chance mais je suis pas
sûr j'avais joué il y a quelques années
un ouzbek qui était très jeune très fort
je sais plus si c'était lui ou pas
mais
bon de toute façon le score il abattre
en faveur sachez
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait ici
Fabien par contre
la partie sur l'activité du roi en
finale le roi on l'active tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps c'est hyper important voilà
réussir à faire nul dans cette finale
on échange le pion il va être honnête
perdu que je peux jouer un coup avant
d'échanger et c'est 6 il prend avec ses
caractères voilà c'est nul direct si ils
font une maintenant il y aura encore une
partie
et je crois que ça fait nul parce que
Abdou qui a l'air
qui a l'air de faire une pause donc je
pense une dernière partie
à moins qu'il la joue
à la pendule
pour ne pas faire d'autre parties en 5
puissance c'est possible
c'est possible que les joueurs
attendent
pour ne pas devoir faire une autre
partie c'est long c'est parti
peut-être qui va attendre pour proposer
une après que le temps soit terminé et
je pense ça va être ça
[Musique]
et c'est pour ça qu'il attend
il veut se refaire en il veut se faire
en Blix il aura les noirs
donc je pense qu'il va se refaire
en blitz mais il a raison un peu enfin
il est mal au temps mais les mené deux
points mais de l'autre côté
voilà ça a sauvé ses œufs le temps donc
maintenant ça c'est un nul
je pense qu'il va faire
donc ça va se changer et ça va faire
mieux
assez facilement voilà maintenant il y a
plus qu'à plus qu'à finir
[Musique]
et il s'est levé donc les parties voilà
c'est tout se changer
et nul ok donc pause encore une fois
avant le changement de cadence donc on
est maintenant à 5 3 en faveur
on est à 5,3 en faveur de l'Américain
hop America
dans ce match et maintenant on va passer
en 5 heures on va passer en trois plus
un pendant une heure il y a une petite
pause de 1 minute entre les deux parties
donc nous on va partir au cellulite pose
je vous dis à tout de suite pour la
suite du match ne bougez pas
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour
pour la suite avec les joueurs qui sont
pas encore arrivés donc je suis un peu
en avance
par rapport aux joueurs on fabrique qui
fait les cent pas
chez lui donc pour l'instant on est à 5
3 ben d'ailleurs je vais rembourser les
gens je vous ai vu vous rappelez vous
avez fait une prédiction pour ce premier
set
et je vais payer donc avec 58 % des gens
qui ont parié sur carvana
dans ce set 37% sur Abdou et 4% sur nul
et je vais choisir Carole carbonara a
gagné ce 7 à 5 3 donc là vous pouvez
voir un petit peu les points qui vous
sont rendus est-ce qu'on se fait encore
une prédiction
sur la partie Blitz je pense qu'on va
faire la même
on va se faire la même si vous voulez je
vous laisse 5 minutes
je prends la même
et bien du 3 + 1
réponse A
réponse C
nul je vous laisse 5 minutes à partir de
maintenant pour parier sur votre favori
donc on va passer des points de chaîne
c'est vous ne perdez pas d'argent vous
ne perdez rien de bien grave c'est les
points de chaîne
qui se gagne en nous regardant en ligne
c'est les points qui sont en dessous du
chat il y a une bulle
pour ceux qui en ont qui en ont plein
vous pouvez ici parier sur le résultat
que vous pensez qui va qui va arriver et
là je vois un all-in sur carwana lors du
deuxième 7 mais quasiment à 100k de
points sur Kawana alors qu'à 12 il est à
0 en vrai Abdou il est extrêmement fort
moi à votre place là le saisir
l'occasion pour miser un peu sur Abdou
pour gagner tout ce qui peut regarder 88
points de chaîne sur Carola entre 0 pour
la nuit de 0 sur Abdou donc pour parier
c'est simple il faut que vous cliquez
sur le truc qui a peint le recul du chat
et vous pariez
la partie qui a commencé on va partir en
3 + 1 avec Fabi qui a les blancs dans
cette première partie donc le score 5 3
en faveur de famille
oline de reboulo et salut Marius
Arcada F3 était joué F4 encore à Londres
de la part de famille
[Musique]
donc c'est la ligne
qui a été jouée on va dire une idée
similaire qu'on voit un français aussi
avec les fous qui s'échangent donc le
bon fou des blancs ils sont en jeu le
mauvais fou des noirs
est très sûrement plus tard on va voir
un truc de style G3 roi les deux et le
roi qui va pouvoir sortir même G4 peu un
jour être uniquement il y a cavalier
catch j'aime pas du tout le coup de G4
mais j'ai trois rois de va être un coup
qui est relativement solide safe le roi
qui se met en sécurité
et
voilà c'est une partie normale
ou des Noirs
je trouve que c'est assez intéressant
petit rock avec les jouets
qui va le 5 on va absolument voir
cavalier 7 ou 15 on va laisser 6 un
petit coup là plutôt cavalier d'ailleurs
je dirais
comment est-ce que
de la part des Noirs ça pourrait être
possible qu'à 5 empêche les coups comme
Descartes Canada 4
parce que B5 c'est un coup je pense que
ça peut être un coup de 5
qui va venir en A4 exactement
j'aime beaucoup la position d'abdo ici
[Musique]
avec les Noirs c'est une bonne
quarantaine ça pour
les Noirs vous savez que le système de
Londres et ben il y a certaines variance
qui peuvent transposer dans des lignes
dans une ligne d'ailleurs de la
carrocane
donc intéressant
des Noirs contre le mauvais fou des
blancs
qui avaler prend
et maintenant cavalier s'écarte va être
une idée mais elle tourne faire vraiment
attention quand on joue cavaler ses
quatre
jouets tour B8
qui est comment est-ce que je continue
pas simplement
[Musique]
je peux pas mettre mes pièces là
vraiment encore
[Musique]
il y a une pression sur le plan A4 qui
empêche le cavalier de bouger
dans l'autre côté
regardez c'est un coup hein
intéressant ce cavalier c'est 4 mais je
ne sais rien je crois
peut-être qu'est-ce qui a été joué il y
a eu cavalier C4 c'est la partie cabel
et B4 a été joué
et là
qui était amélioré je peux manger avec
le prévoyance C4 c'est possible c'est de
carré en B4 mais il tient un peu la
baraque il empêche la pression sur le
plan B2 des tours par exemple
j'arrive pas trop à m'activer mais
cavaliers prend celui qu'elle va laisser
4 et un à trois un jour peut être aussi
des cavaliers
je viens de le voir
je vous dis un peu n'importe quoi perd
la dame
la prise en E5 rectifie ce que j'avais
dit donc avalé des six
tarif 3 peut-être maintenant qu'elle va
laisser 4
mais si j'ai pas envie de faire
généralement parce que j'avais quand
même pas mal
les cases blanches donc les passions de
vraiment vouloir faire F6 un jour dans
la partie donc avaliser 5 ce pion
on va quand même s'habille qui a réussi
à verser la tendance dans cette position
ça c'est incroyable donc cavalier qui
était un peu à la rue qui a mis en B4
qui est revenu en C5 et maintenant les
Noirs arrivent plus à attaquer la la
base de la chaîne de pions
il est sous pression un peu de partout
sur ça là
la structure qui est à la fois active
mais à la fois solide sur casse blanche
pas évident
ça c'est nenderre aussi
il y a juste normal dans mes 4 qui avait
laissé quatre pour le moment
tout le temps d'un F5 on va venir sur
les cases blanches attention en dessin
quand il faut le défendre tu es toujours
de mes fesses
moi j'aime bien dans la ficelle je
contrôle un peu les cases blanches
toutes les 15 ans autour de autour de
mon roi et même j'étais G6 c'est mon
Stone plus tard je suis pas fan de
bouger les pions du roi peut-être quand
même que je pourrais améliorer la
pollution le contrôler un peu on arrive
ça c'est mon coup favori je sais pas si
je raconte un truc mais
c'est un coup qui a l'air
un problème sur le pion à cadre a été
joué 30 secondes pour pour Abdou ici
contre 52 pour
famille
en direct
c'est le mot qu'on utilise pour dire
qu'on est en crise de temps on est mal
au temps qu'il faut jouer vite c'est un
mot allemand
tu prends là je prends l'échec
est-ce qu'il y a j'arrive à revenir
après on est d'accord
OK
comment je peux défendre à la fois
cavalier et mes deux sur cavaliers
à 6 on reprend l'air pas mal B2 elle a
pas mal aussi
je pense c'est pareil mais justement le
sur roi derrière
sont toujours là à trouver du
contre-jour
ça c'est incroyable B2 tour ici va être
joué obligatoire et 6
ok
je me lâche pour B6 comme ça
en seconde chacun c'est extrêmement
chaud ton S7 si je mange là les cavalier
bouge tu reviens à manger depuis
c'est la folie les coups qui trouvent
avec très peu de temps les joueurs sont
juste beaucoup trop fort en fait pour
ces 6 tu prends mes deux à la fin tu
perds ces trois
ça reste quand même
pas mal pour Abdou ici qui je pense
qu'il va il risque de vraiment
s'imposer dans cette partie il va venir
à -1 sur le score je pense c'est quand
même bien pour l'intérêt du match Abdou
revienne
Oscar tour ici j'ai 5 tours c'est pas
grave il y a tort C4 pour prendre des
quatre rois ici en train de dire
prise on mange là
alors G4 c'est un coup volontaire ou
ouais je pense à
ça ressemble aussi à une faute de souris
le coup G4
et on va pousser les pions maintenant et
ça a l'air juste abandon un mois
attention que les pions avant ça ce que
tu arrives à me faire un truc
waouh on a l'impression que les pions
vont s'échanger
ici est-ce que comment je peux activer
échec si je prends je regarde c'est une
autre direct la finale a fait du dehors
on connaît
et maintenant comment je passe
ouais apparemment c'est ça a l'air
d'être proche de l'égalité et chaque roi
là mais j'ai roi là après peut-être
c'était tellement compliqué en pratique
ça va défendre il y a deux secondes
chacun c'est un peu la loterie
c'est un peu
à ce roi
OK
c'est une loterie je prends rien F3 donc
sur pour apprendre
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux gagner que le noir là
ça gagne et oui roi bouge je prends roi
prend et je passe mon roi ici et ici ça
gagne
incroyable en fait cette position à la
fin c'était nul effectivement mais
tellement compliqué avec si peu de temps
en fait que
[Musique]
que c'est un jouable hein vous avez 4
secondes dans la pendule qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire quoi ça va trop vite
alors Abdou qui a changé d'ouverture
ok donc ici faut B7 donc 5 4 pour
pour s'habille dans ce match et 1-0 pour
Abdou dans ce set
un zéro pour le 7
qui peut aussi être un coup
et sur un 4
fois
65 ans
F3 annule contrairement à la règle
générale surtout la fin j'ai droit de
effectivement mais genre vraiment plus
de temps si elle bleu que
en fait
ambulette c'est bon il y a pas d'erreur
normal
c'est normal et c'est le copain
bienvenue à toi
donc là on est à 5 4 pour pour fabino
kavalin dans ce match là il y a 5 3 en 5
+ 1 là il est mené 1-0 dans le 3 + 1 et
une partie de folie qui va se terminer
ou
Fabiano était
[Musique]
perdant puis c'était nul puis la part du
donc avec ces cadences où il y a quand
même ça va quand même très très vite
mais c'est difficile vraiment de de
de se faire un peu sa propre opinion il
se passe plein de choses
ça change tout le temps même si c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde
qui est à la recherche de Marius est-ce
que Marius est-ce que Marius est sur le
chat
fait ça fait un petit moment qu'il est
il tient fou en fait je crois qu'il
devient fou il vient un fou
qui est ce Marius qui le connaît
et Marius ne pas la chaîne info
c'est responsable quand même on reste on
reste ici donc j'imagine que dame d'un
B7 va être
va être la menace sur échec moi j'aurais
préféré dame C8 quand même perso
mesdames des 7 ça m'a valable
assez bizarre en vrai
mais Durc punien il y a pas de
découverte je crois
donc apparemment c'est un coup à deux
points d'interrogation
si vous aviez la jauge je pense que la
jauge a été tout là haut tout là haut
tout là haut
donc B5 d'un MP3 pourquoi je vais mettre
lors d'une petite seconde juste pour
vous trouver pourquoi parce que nous on
n'a pas vu ça va trop vite
ok mais pourquoi
pourquoi
ok bon trop dur trop dur
introuvable F5 B5 d'un B3 prise et cave
à l'écran faut j'ai 5 donc toujours
pareil
[Musique]
les blancs qui ont beaucoup d'activités
qu'elle a des cinq peut être joué le roi
un peu ouvert mais je pense c'est pas
très grave envoyer les pièces noires
sont beaucoup trop loin de l'attaque je
peux rien faire
du tout
et le thème de partout il y a des thèmes
de partout dans la position tours
ok la tour était en prison je l'avais
pas vu
donc pour cela était joué avec 37
secondes à la pendule pour pour Abdou
alors Abdou qui qui est un peu lent dans
ce matin on avait déjà parlé tout à
l'heure m'a demandé si on pensait que
Abdoul pouvait faire la différence en
tout ce qui est
Blitz et Bulex et j'avais dit que je
sais pas parce que c'est vrai que que
c'est un joueur qui est un peu complet
moi un peu comme comme s'habille mais on
n'a jamais vraiment vu jouer dans les
cadences un peu plus rapide que ça et là
c'est vrai quand même que j'ai
l'impression qu'il est un petit peu il
est un petit peu lent ma famille en tout
cas dans ce match et ça me fait peur
parce que c'est vrai que c'est important
je pense d'essayer de de
gagner un peu l'initiative essayer de
jouer vite pour mettre la pression
adversaire tout ça
et quand tu es lent c'est difficile on
peut se tromper quand on a mal au temps
et à la fois Adam mesdames je garde les
deux
et au final Fabi qui s'en sortir
quand même malgré tout
il y a failli avoir un petit mal sympa
avec des seins qui avaient le 7
tours
voilà je vous mets tout et je mets quoi
Abdou c'est bien il a tout compris
en échange des pièces total un peu
arrivé
que des 5 waouh ça marche oui ça marche
tu reprends je prends ici et je prends
la
croix et fuite qu'elle va les prendre
set pour apprendre qui est C8 ah ouais
mais what
complètement oublié la pièce en un
incroyable point cadeau le point cadeau
pour Fabi
à lucinant ah oui sinon elle est pas en
forme en ce match
n'est pas vraiment en forme en ce match
Abdou il fait des cadeaux
il fait des cadeaux il est bleu points
et vu le point qui vient de donner
j'ai pas vu la suite
on peut pas trop trop analyser mais
malheureusement j'ai pas pu voir
[Musique]
mais bon qui avait laissé vite c'est une
faute kraft quand même dans le mal
d'avant enfin dans le 7 d'avant il a
donné 80 coups qui a pas été mangé
d'ailleurs c'était un cavalier qui était
laissé en D6 tout seul et là ça fait
aussi encore une fois une pièce donnée
donc ça va quand même que ça serait
beaucoup quand même normalement on fait
des erreurs parce que du Blitz ça va
vite
mais c'est quand même des erreurs quand
même très très grossière c'est les
erreurs que
que
même si moi qui l'ai fait je suis
vraiment petite quoi alors que eux ils
sont bien meilleurs que moi donc
le contrecoup du terrestre c'est vrai
que d'où il était au tactile India
glitter rapide qui se terminaient du
coup hier je sais plus quand est-ce que
c'est en train de terminer donc
ouais
[Musique]
ça fait quelques temps qui est plus trop
en forme là il a fait aussi le speech il
a pas été par enfant tabasse-t-il mais
c'est pas non plus
pas en plus
si impressionnant que ça
mais il a une période de fou il est en
feu des fois plus de creux donc bon à
voir si samedi on est lundi après il a
dû rentrer chez lui quand même donc
voyager sur mon dimanche
je le lundi non c'est clair que bon la
fatigue le tournoi c'est ça va sûrement
ça joue sûrement
mais
[Musique]
c'est dur B4 là j'aime beaucoup la
prochaine fois
une belle position il y a plein d'espace
qui avait lieu le 4
car il prend il y a toujours un truc qui
va tomber après
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici c'est quand
même une très très mauvaise pièce
très très mauvaise pièce
Dame des deux
en Coupe du Monde premier tour je crois
premier
tour de la Coupe du monde
la part de qui déjà
j'ai un trou de mémoire je sais plus qui
l'a perdu mais il a perdu au premier
tour
peut-être c'était un je crois que
c'était un Turc à 2006 non c'est comme
ça
il a parlé d'une partie et bon ça arrive
ça arrive il a perdu en partie lente je
crois
sans vouloir dire en partie lente il a
fait une bêtise la part de la partie
[Musique]
les systèmes système coupe c'est un peu
chaud parce que dès que tu perds une
partie
en fait tu as un gros danger pour être
éliminé donc c'est un système qui
qui
est on n'a pas l'autre jour avec Laurent
quand il passe sur la chaîne
qui est intéressant mais qui quand même
peut être très sévère
on a aussi Magnus café est très éliminé
il a fait une grosse bêtise pour gamer
en finale
alors qu'elle est une position qui était
très très proche de la nul et avant de
faire nul il l'a donné un pion quoi
et il a fallu sortir à cause de ça quoi
au final après il a gagné l'année
dernière enfin il a gagné l'autre partie
classique il a gagné de partage etc mais
tu peux avoir des très gros joueurs qui
se qui s'éliminent attention il faut que
je rage de je pense peut-être le fou un
F4 et G3 derrière pour colmater un peu
ça mal ok ouais merci et c'est bien toi
Fontenoy
bienvenue sur le stream donc plus qu'une
minute chacun là pour ce joueur alors
qu'on est à 6 4 pour l'instant dans ce
match
le plus récent qui va tomber
pas du tout la pollution des
Noirs je trouve que là il y a tout qui
se casse un petit peu la figure
c'est d'avoir cavaler F4 d'avoir en tant
qu'avait là ce que je pouvais F4
du F5 pour enterrer le fou et puis elles
sont extrêmement mauvaises
ça risque d'être ouais ça va être trop
dur mais qui est encore mal au temps en
plus d'être pas bien pensé parti
alors je vois que le gagnant du match
bon c'est une bonne nouvelle quand tu
regardes le match généralement c'est une
bonne nouvelle tu es contente personne
étape mais le gagnant je compte ma carte
donc
voilà peut-être que peut-être que Abdou
il a pas envie de se taper 3 ans
d'accord aussi comprendre
donc
à contre moi on se retrouve facile
pour eux je dis mais contre Naka
généralement tu peux être tu peux
n'importe qui en face mais tu pas le
malin on va les gens qui sont pas
contents du tout
et ah ok c'est trop loin c'est trop
abdos c'est trop hein ça fait échec sur
ton plan je prends la dame je vais une
tour c'est trop abdos il est vraiment
vraiment pas en forme
c'est dur
c'est dur mais moi à sa place je suis
pas content de me prendre un petit
tactique très facile comme ça
c'est très très dur
la fille je suis d'accord ciel bleu
entièrement d'accord avec toi
H3 X5
manger car les dessins
et
Fabi qui commence à prendre un peu le
large avec un petit 7 4 un saveur dans
ce match et un petit 2 1 dans ce 7 alors
j'hésiste un coup qui est assez rare on
l'a vu il y a pas longtemps c'était je
crois au championnat de test tour et bon
on a de l'huile cette partie avec G6
d'ailleurs je me demande si c'était pas
dans leur match à eux
me demande que je crois que c'était
c'était Abdou Carolin ils ont déjà la
même partie au
donc
va arriver
et c'est une pause qui est quand même
très facile à jouer pour
pour
[Musique]
le blanc parce que les blancs vont jouer
F5 ils vont jouer 5 en fait c'est des
blancs qui poussent un peu
bien sûr c'est pas encore clair
mais les Noirs attendent que les Blancs
fassent un choix sur F5 songe ou F6 pour
venir sur le 15 novembre
et sur 5 je sais pas comment ça va ce
jouer exactement mais sans que
c'est fort moi j'aime bien le petit coup
au single
il y a eu H4 de jouer pour les
Paradou
et comment je veux que les noirs
je mange tout
et
tous deux
par 5 je pense c'est l'idée de la
position dans ce 5 alors
H2 est un coup qui empêche aussi
d'assurer un peu et d'améliorer la
position vous savez que pas toujours
essayer d'améliorer la position entre le
parti il a fait dame F2 à table de 4
c'est juste pour
la CDS menacé le 5 et c'est la pression
sur le plan des 4 ok dame j'ai 4
c'est la menace
la prise ici il y avait eu 6
maintenant
et absolument revenir en ce match il a
-3 et il peut pas attendre on peut plus
attendre on peut plus
faire de faire de fautes comme ça
E5 a été joué
[Musique]
la prise prise avec la tour qui pour
attaquer la dame en G4
Tour Eiffel 1
fois
enfin je pense que j'ai l'horaire
intention attendez je pense que je peux
avoir l'horaire
ça a changé chez moi parce que
aujourd'hui
mais finalement ça a changé demain
ça joue demain demain on est le 12
septembre à demain ça joue
et l'horaire
du matin
péter c'est pas pété
ça veut dire 13h30 en France
donc demain 13h30
demain 13h30 heure française ça va en
fait vous aurez Maxime contre kookesh
ça veut dire enfin je sais pas combien
de décalages horaires on a entre mais
du coup ça va
très heureux demain
dans ce match
vers le roi G7 maintenant que j'y pense
c'était pas du tout c'était caroanna qui
l'a vu que les Noirs contre
contre Prague en Coupe du monde je sais
pas si ça vous parle il y a eu un D4 et
ce pion qui est tombé une partie que
Prague a gagné en Coupe du monde contre
contre karwana la première victoire de
Prague dans ce départage c'était cette
ligne exactement
où Fabi avait perdu ce pion en E3
mauvais souvenir de
pour Fabi mais
ok là j'aime bien les blancs
nulle part et puis j'ai quand même des
plombs qui peuvent avancer là ça peut
être embêtant j'aime beaucoup les blancs
aussi
je sais pas quel était décalage horaire
donc demain 13h30 vous avez
vous avez mvl
qui Google
française
et
[Musique]
vous aurez juste après à 19h demain le
match de match
qui rentre qui rentre en lice et Magnus
il affronte
mais je suis pas sûr couvert
j'ai un doute c'est ma news
c'est bien ça
et ça se passe pas bien là pour lui
ouais
encore une défaite je pense pour Abdou
qui est en train de complètement
complètement
se faire avoir dans ce match
je peux me faire tourner à deux en fait
c'est juste complètement perdu et
qui va être probablement abandon et toi
à deux qui arrivent
c'est terminé
incroyable ce matin qui prend une
mauvaise tournure pour pour
Abdou qui qui maintenant un petit peu à
la rue avec 8 cartes Maintenant donc il
y a un + 4 pour pour Fabi et donc là il
reste encore une demi-heure de 3 + 1 et
une demi-heure de Bullet donc ça va être
chaud ça va être très très chaud il peut
encore revenir dans ce match clairement
il en a les
capacités mais il faut commencer
maintenant à bien revenir parce que
c'est ça commence à être très très
difficile voilà je vous laisse une
minute on revient très très vite pour la
suite je pense que les devoirs vont
revenir là très rapidement je vous dis à
tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'émoticônes et même
vos personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs ils émoticônes et les emojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales
restent sur les chéquiers jusqu'à ce
qu'elles soient effacées pour ce faire
il suffit de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'emoji ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title
tuesday.com/aventem tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour avec les joueurs qui
s'installent donc on va avoir maintenant
je me suis trompé de scène on va voir un
carwana avec les Blancs je vous mets la
bonne scène contre
dernière portion de Blitz en tropicule
qui reste encore une demi-heure de 3
plus une avant de passer en Bullet une
plus une pour ce mal pourquoi il y a 8 4
pour pour s'habiller
j'ai rien fait j'ai rien fait
j'ai rien fait
c'est pas très malin
je vais monter un petit peu mon
mon ordre que je suis un peu bas je suis
bien sur la ligne votre milieu là
les gens qui sont installés
ici et la partie qui a pas encore
démarré donc il y aura des blancs 29
parties 29 minutes
2 3 plus 1 ça fait environ 4 5 parties
donc il faut vraiment que que Abdou
essaye d'en gagner au moins
au moins de faire un petit plus de quoi
pour essayer de revenir après en Bullet
pas évident mais
les programmes
en fait il a commencé le confinement
enfin ça commençait le confinement Fabi
il faisait enfin il était pas bon en
blitz alors
pas bon bien sûr par rapport à son
niveau là il y a aucun une grosse
différence
mais du coup il a beaucoup travaillé ça
pendant confinement et il s'est dit il
est tellement de tournois avec tous les
manuses tout ça au final je suis obligé
quand même je suis obligé de faire un
tournoi pour enfin je suis obligé de
progresser en bide parce que maintenant
il y a tout qui s'accélère toutes les
cadences s'accélèrent ce soit tout droit
sur Internet tout de même en live donc
il a été obligé de
de
s'entraîner et de bosser là-dessus
donc je pense qu'il a réellement pour
lui aussi en blitz
et puis là c'est vrai que dans ce match
là il faut dire qu'à tout il est pas en
forme
j'ai beaucoup d'erreurs
terrain un peu d'enfant quoi beaucoup de
tactiques ratées de la part d'Abdou qui
est là d'être fatigué quand même fatigué
après son son tournoi
tata style
d'ailleurs le rapide qui a été remporté
par un Maxime
VL
et le Blitz par par quelque chose
et donc là on a sans là dessus avec avec
Laurent Freyssinet qui était commentaire
et donc oui c'est je pense qu'il est
fatigué après tout ce temps là c'est
quand même long
c'est pas évident d'enchaîner dès que tu
rentres avec un match contre
la maison il a pas joué le
tournoi rapide des Blitz donc vraiment
c'était
quand même
plus facile on va dire niveau santé pour
famille ce match
que pour
vraiment vraiment en difficulté
donc
B55
mais c'est vrai que ça laisse des choses
en l'air je sais pas si c'est bien ou
pas
c'est la partie
qu'est-ce que je joue pour défendre ce
pion c'est Madame B5 qui a des sept
c'est possible
mais quelle est cette
il n'y a pas de
chercher des trucs
qui peut forcer la prise de la paire de
fou c'est pour ça que j'aimais pas trop
l'idée de jouer cadet
je pense que il y a vraiment intéressant
es mais à la fois faible sur le long
terme soupection il peut être perdu
et pareil pour le plan à 5 aussi les
pions à 6 c'est les positions assez
intéressantes
cette structure assis on a vu dans le
match car voilà contrat la Coupe du
monde dans la partie lente la deuxième
partie lente ou carlave elle est blanc
une grosse pression sur le pion à 6 pour
donc pas évident du tout à gérer
toujours à cette défendre ce pion
solide
et maintenant comment on joue
C4
changer les fous
ces quatre
plus tard je peux échanger les pièces et
mettre la caméra de 5 une belle idée à
sa stratégie
au moins ça et ça je pense que j'ai pas
mal de
l'activité il a vu qu'il y a des scènes
direct ok prise tu reprends tous ces
quatre
hop et plus tard je mange ici il y a un
problème sur F7
c'est hyper bien c'est ce que fait ici
la vie qui continue à jouer vite et bien
très difficile dans ce match pour Abdou
ok même si c'est 80 pas mal
je suis conscient que je donne des cases
mais en fait t'es pas atteignable
C3 je vais faire doubler sur la colonne
D c'est pion qui va être perdu peut-être
sur le long terme j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup la pollution de sa vie je pense
qu'il va encore la gagner quoi bien sûr
comme d'habitude
il a déjà sorti mvl au CC
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je me souviens qu'il aille
battu
ambulette stambulette il est battu
alors que karena tout le monde disait
ouais mais il est pas bon ampli il est
pas bon ambulette il est pas bon non mvl
ça a été le Bullet etc tout le monde
disait ça et il a perdu en Bullet de ce
match je me souviens très bien c'est en
bulle et qu'il a perdu et d'ailleurs ce
match c'est moi qui les commentaires
en direct d'Argentine j'étais un Buenos
Aires buenos aides à ce moment là c'est
un de mes premiers streams
on se fait un très bien pour moi c'était
un peu une nouveauté
dans mes trois avec les jouets je laisse
ces 5 mais tu laisses C5 il y avait un
cavalier
on revient ici on va jouer B4
ça va être perdu
une seule partie
pas avoir gagné une seule partie
parce que
moi je sais aussi quand j'avais aussi
commenté le match
Carlsen contre carvana ou carolas
donc quand on dit quand on dit adopter
en terme de chien c'est quand on perd
enfin en fait c'est quand tu perds je
pense
c'est quand tu perds 10 fois d'affilée
dans le même enfin voilà quand tu perds
c'est se faire adopter
et les choses qui peuvent arriver là
même B5 là
c'est trois il y a plus de temps là
ok
avantage noir un niveau de
des possibilités regarder là attention 7
secondes joue faut jouer là c'est 6
c'est ça qui arrive waouh c'est
extrêmement dur
tu gardes le chèque ça fait nul je pense
pas répétition mais c'est quand même un
beau sauvetage
car voilà qui était quoi ici un beau
sauvetage sauvetage de
kerwana qui finit par faire match nul il
reste 20 minutes dans ce match est
toujours à + 4
ah oui non mais
c'est clair que en fait entre les deux
joueurs il y a tellement
des psychologiques entre Magnus et Fabi
je pense enfin j'ai l'impression et
c'est dur mais en de le jouer avec tout
ce qui s'est passé mais bon après
on peut c'est intense de finit ah oui
non mais quand tu es pas en forme
et ton adversaire il est hyper en forme
il t'écrase quoi c'est insupportable
ment
comment ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe entre ces deux
joueurs
ils sont en train de jouer
tours
de moins il est réduit à trois
OK
donc
peu importe ce qui s'est passé avant
dans son passé
avec Hans mais je pense que maintenant
il a compris la leçon en tout cas je
pense pas que qui va recommencer à faire
ce qu'il a fait avant sur Internet
c'est vraiment un abruti
je pense que maintenant
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi si elle
le dans les dans les premiers les
premières fois que je l'ai vu c'était
ton Allemagne où il avait je crois qu'il
est d'air il avait battu Magnus il avait
dit il avait dit
chaise speak for it
et ça m'avait j'avais pas aimé son
attitude
et après bon qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
c'est autre chose enfin ce qu'il a fait
ou pas fait en tout cas les débats qu'il
y a contre lui c'est un grand autre
chose mais c'est que j'aime pas trop le
personnage de base
toute la vérité
un joueur qui m'inspire pas confiance
par rapport à son attitude j'aime pas
l'habitude j'aime pas les il fait un peu
le gars un peu pas de Boy
et j'aime pas trop ça mais après bon ce
qu'il a tout ce qui s'est passé
avec l'histoire cars etc c'est encore
c'est autre chose d'ailleurs on saura
jamais si s'il y a eu un truc ou pas
mais bon
et j'aime beaucoup la position blanche
là
de voir si vraiment j'arrive à
avoir un avantage avec les avec les
Blancs parce que plus je change de pièce
plus
ça va ça planning tout ça
incroyable je sais pas si
ouais mais je c'est ce que je pensais
pareil que toi ça va
être en cours
ok alors
tour D8
Cavani c'est 6 avant ou peut-être
sûrement manque
c'est très probable donc maintenant
c'est possible parce que maintenant il y
aura un problème sur la
sur un tour des 6 et de retour là il y
aura toujours d'enfants mais avant je
pense je pense que tu avais raison et
qu'il y avait il y avait bien cette idée
de faire cavaler ces 6 c'est sûrement
dans
la reine de
d'Abdou est-ce que tout là est possible
mais bon d'un BTS
quand même
on voit bien que les Noirs
même si les pions sont moches ah si
c'est à 4 il y a toujours des problèmes
sur les pions à 3 B2 donc
elle va les prendre pour reprendre
mais il va falloir quand même pas trop
envie de laisser ce qu'elle va les
prendre ici c'est une folie il faut
manger je pense pouvoir faire
aussi possible
peut-être juste
ce petit coup actif qui vient intelliger
la dame qui vient de faire des petites
choses pour B7 on joue plus solide
allez 30 secondes pour faire 25
une position qui est mieux pour les
blancs les blancs qui ont contrôle les
colonnes c'est donc qui peut tomber mais
attention
j'ai l'impression que la chance de dame
a favorise quand même la position de
famille maintenant on ramène le roi donc
bien sûr les blancs sont plein avancés
c'est pas clair et toutes les blancs
et Abdou qui est encore une fois à
laisser passer ta chance
elle s'est passé la chance tomber 6 il y
a plus de temps
cette position je pense que la tendre à
pas tranquille
c'est quoi l'idée il veut
tour B2
à 5
et il a rendu un pion il a rendu un pion
attention
plus de temps d'un pendule donc j'ai 5
tours là
pour C4 tours c'est 6 ok un pion de plus
mais attention
ça reste ça reste pas évident c'est
blanc qui pousse maintenant je pion
peut passer ici pour chaque qui va
arriver
il faut qu'on gagne c'est je pense
gagnant mais
attention il faut
pas se tromper il y a plus de temps la
bonne nuit à 3 secondes chacun là tout
peut arriver
tout peut arriver
qui est le tournage je pense
ça et perdu autant incroyable car voilà
qui perd autant pour cette partie donc
un Blue qui revient quand même
il revient un petit peu
avec un 5 et demi
donc plus que trois points de retard
c'est encore beaucoup mais ok c'est
abdougat c'est parti et bien commencera
le Bullet avec moins de ce qui est tout
à fait jouable avant ce match
avec les deux
il doit être mal entouré voir pas
entouré
des snaps
je crois que c'est je crois que c'est
même
B4 A5 thématique à 5 mais ici peut-être
pas
retourner en défendant ici tout un
problème car G4 cavalier avec le roi ici
j'aime bien je pense que j'aurais 42
et d'ailleurs il y a plein de positions
où en fait et ben les blancs
pour garder la tour en H1 des fois la
tour en champ peut servir pour jouer H4
H5 quand la pollution est fermée comme
ça des fois je peux je peux ne pas
manquer
d'ailleurs
le roi a pris va rester ici mais là moi
j'aime bien voir
que j'aime pas ah il fait mon plan
Sabine
en fait on veut mettre le roi à l'abri
mais on veut aussi garder la tour sur la
canne parce qu'on sait que il y a des
ruptures qui peuvent arriver et
j'aime beaucoup le roi F1 rangée 2 de
Fabi c'est ce que j'aurais fait ouais
j'aurais fait la même je pense salut
esthero
il faut que j'arrive à là où là mais le
problème c'est que dès que je passe là
et là je perds le plan de 4 mais
peut-être cavalier
c'est pas sûr avoir
très passif
j'aime beaucoup le plan de dame C3
mettre le cavalier en deux trois puis à
lancer 5 et après pousser les pions
ouais je pense que ça va être c'est en
tout cas une belle domination de famille
ici avec les Blancs connaissez-vous la
différence entre moi
tu me fais peur
tome 3 donc 1 2 3 et je
soupçonne entre amis
mon plan ce serait bon plan
j'aime beaucoup ce plan là
[Musique]
c'est quand même pas mal du tout
il y a un bout qui est un peu en PLS la
position qui est très très dur pour pour
les Noirs ce cavalier qui va arriver
alors cavalier ici du coup
ok je peux me le pion mais attention ce
pion
je m'ouvre le roi en face quand tu
prends il faut être sur le toit bon
t'arrives pas à mettre ton cavalier sur
la bonne case
alors ça ça a l'air quand même très très
dur à
défendre
ça va être trop dur pour pour
mais pas découvert parce que tu la boue
je contrôle le garder chaque en fait
donc
c'est l'idée mais je pense qu'il fallait
le prendre ce pion obligé en fait je
suis pas le pion et ben tu autorises un
cavalier en F4 vu qu'il y avait un pion
noir en G5 et là c'est pas forcément
cool
ok attention
c'est un peu gênant quand même j'ai pas
aimé
si je reviens là et ben je perds
plus défendre à cause du Caballé devant
et si je fais le tourner
4 sur Tours il y aura tout reprend j'ai
5 probablement
ok c'est chaud qui peut arriver derrière
genre pouf pouf
pouf pouf
alors
ok pas clair
tout le monde va répondre ici 50
secondes
contre 15 avec toujours une seconde
parcours je vous rappelle il reste 5
minutes sur le timer
sur le timer donc on aura sûrement une
partie supplémentaire
à jouer c'est un faux F3 cavalier 4 rois
d'un E3 peut-être ah mais tu prends et
tu prends l'as mais je prends mes sets à
la fin
elles sont un peu trois je prends et je
fais B6 et ce pion avec un défendable ça
a commencé à être intéressant pour le
boire même si ce
un des deux plutôt bêtises
que j'avais dit
et maintenant voilà F6 et
ouais ça va être nul mec le petit
cavalier
c'est un cavalier c'est un peu ça peut
être fouille
qui fait des fourchettes ce cavaler un
petit peu traîner un petit peu
toujours un peu traîner
ou pas
[Musique]
F7 mais tu manges à 5 c'est très très
chaud comme ce qui se passe là
on prend des risques
il a raison parce que
parce que il est il a moins trois en
terme de score vous voyez il est mené
deux trois points donc il a raison de
pouvoir prendre un peu des risques mais
attention parce que là maintenant ce
piétonne joue plus si il bouge le fou il
parle
son pion qui va avancer aussi super là
là ça a commencé à être non c'est Fabi
qui joue pour gagner
ma vie
cavalier F6 peut-être on se sait on
ramène le roi ici
j'aime bien
échec peut-être
à chaque fois
si je bouge le fou je le laisse une
entrée
voilà
pas passer le roi
c'est quand même
cavalier à 5 peut-être avec béton
[Musique]
je vais bien ce qu'il avait fait à
demain
et plus de temps elle a pendule de la
c'est extrêmement chaud
qui va peut-être
qu'il y a la partie bas c'est fini
d'ailleurs
reste une seule partie dans ce time
une seule partie
donc là du coup on est à on est à moins
de dans ce match
Abdou qui revient bien quand même à deux
qui revient bien
à 6 et demi
dans ce match et ça c'est la dernière
partie
de deux Blitz en 3 + 1 avant la pause et
avant la dernière la dernière
portion en
une plus une ah oui c'est clair en même
pour moi enfin moi je mets à la suivre
quand ils sont plus de temps enfin ça
ajoute trop vite et c'est très très dur
donc en fait
le match il se joue en trois segments de
temps différents vous avez le premier
segment c'est du 5 + 1 donc 5 minutes
avec une seconde parcours à chaque fois
parce que c'est une bonne couleur non je
suis désolé j'ai oublié de changer la
désolée merci le copains les blancs
Abdou et donc on joue
on est simple
ça marche
ou je suis fou
ça marche je suis fou
ça marche
ça marche comment ça va fatiguer si moi
je voulais tactique que eux ne voient
pas c'est que ça c'est qu'il y a un
problème quand même là on parle quand
même des meilleurs joueurs du monde
et donc du coup je disais que oui alors
on a
cinq une heure trente en 5 minutes une
seconde parcours à la fin de cette 1h30
et ben on passe dans le segment
et on joue une heure en trois plus une
donc trois minutes plus une seconde
parcours
et ensuite on joue en 30 minutes
par contre tu t'enjous en une minute
plus une seconde parcours
les points s'additionnent la volonté
en 3 + 1 pour la santé et 1 + 1 ça va se
jouer juste après
cette partie parce que tout en haut en
dessous des caméras vous avez 3 + 1 avec
0,02.00 c'est le temps qui est arrivé à
zéro donc la partie se termine et après
cette partie et ben on va passer en
[Musique]
en comment dire en Bullet en une plus
une pendant 30 minutes
donc
généralement on joue sur la couleur
de son fou donc
c'est logique c'est normal
qui va venir comme ça que la tour ici il
faudra attaquer là-bas pas évident
justement ou pas
c'est chaud
sans calculer je me dis mais il y a des
trucs ah pardon qu'est-ce que je fais
qu'est-ce que je fais si je fais 4 je
vous dis n'importe quoi moi aussi je
suis fatigué un peu donne des pièces en
un coup
il y a 8 ans
n'a pas été mangé
et surtout aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer ici tour 1 ou
tourner deux mais bon
[Musique]
en Bullet
ça va être
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant donc
quasiment toutes les parties qu'on a vu
après cette offre est très très souvent
très souvent en retard autant
en général donc j'ai peur que
ambulette il se fasse un peu écrasé
autant on va voir
mais en tout cas
[Musique]
après je sais pas si vous voyez ça mais
j'ai l'impression que
Abdou il a l'air très fatigué en tout
cas
je le vois il y a vraiment fatigué alors
que
cajouana normale
les petits yeux en tout cas en bas on
voit qu'il se force un petit peu à
essayer de pas être évident
il revienne un gros tournoi il est
rentré hier on retournoy Abdou et du
coup il est
il doit être très très fatigué
mais chez lui parce que j'ai reconnu
chez lui moi j'ai la j'ai des caméras de
devant et derrière ce qui a des systèmes
anti-rich pour voir un petit peu
c'est genre triche pas donc on a des
caméras de
toute la salle et je sais qu'il est chez
lui j'avais déjà vu déjà fait des
événements où j'avais déjà vu le décor
de chez lui et je crois qu'il est chez
lui
un décalage horaire dans quelle heure
quelle heure est-il
en Ouzbékistan
ça lance un
pour ceux qui pour les spécialistes
alors tourgé 5 millions
donc
pas forcément très bon
1 heure du matin en plus
OK
incroyable
[Musique]
master au hasard vous savez
il y a ça en prise je viens là
sur ça il y a match
donc voilà obligé c'est Tamlin
il y a trop de menaces
et Abdou qui fait la grosse remontada
avec il me semble trois victoires
d'affilées pour pour terminer ce set
avec du coup northerberg qui gagne ce
set donc je vais d'ailleurs commencer
par vous rendre vos points donc la
prédiction plein de 7 il y avait 62 %
des gens qui ont parié sur Kawana
29% qui ont parié sur Abdou et 9 % qui
ont parié sur la nul je vais choisir le
résultat et ici je vais mettre du coup
Abdou qui a gagné le 7 de 4 et demi à
3,5 et à bout du coup qui revient
à seulement un point de différence
dans ce match donc on est donc je vais
mettre le point parce qu'on n'est pas
encore à jour hop 8 et demi 7 et demi
donc plus qu'un point de retard avant
les bullets donc là on va voir une
demi-heure de partie en une plus une
donc ça va aller très très vite
en plus c'est de des meilleurs joueurs
du monde qui vont s'affronter donc
franchement vous allez voir c'est ultra
impressionnant restez sur la chaîne
machine pause de 5 minutes et je reviens
pour le dénouement de ce très très beau
match entre karwana et Abdou je vous dis
à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris à du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chains.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
je suis de retour pour ce match qui va
reprendre ici quelques minutes quelques
instants donc je vais un peu vos
messages salut Ghislain 06
oui en fait il y a un décalage entre les
entre les parties qu'on voit ici et les
caméras il y a 15 secondes de décalage
il me semble
pour éviter un peu la triche de la
dextérieur
donc bien évidemment
bien évidemment
c'est pour ça que on voit pas les les
quand on voit qu'il y a un joueur qui
fait
vraiment 15 secondes après on comprend
pourquoi pourquoi il a fait ça voilà
voilà
c'est un décalage et pour répondre aussi
aux questions que j'ai sur Youtube alors
Clément qui me demande à combien de
points on change la cadence en fait tu
vois en haut en haut à gauche tu as un
timer qui se met en place et donc dès
que ça à 0 il y a pas de partie c'est le
timer qui change dès que ça arrive à
zéro et pour danoter terrassier qui nous
demande où est-ce que quand est-ce que
Maxime joue Maxime joue demain à 13h30
demain à 13h30
et ensuite plus tard dans la soirée je
sais pas quelle heure on aura Magnus
contre l'idée donc deux gros gros match
demain mardi
moi je serai pas là je pourrai pas les
commenter ni l'un ni l'autre le premier
c'est Keane qui va le commenter Kevin
qui a une bordille victime et le
deuxième c'est pas sûr à 100% que ça
commentait faut avoir mais je ne
pourrais pas être là pour le commenter
malheureusement j'ai des choses à faire
et oui ça va néo ça va ça fait ça fait
trois heures vingt de stream pour
l'instant on va arriver à 4
mais on a l'habitude
allez du coup
c'est quand même mieux quand on est en
croix que la caméra mais après bon on
sait jamais avec tout ce qui peut se
passer je trouve ça cool moi de pouvoir
mettre
comment dire
des mesures en effet au cas où en tout
cas ça peut décourager les gens de le
faire
même si bon bah c'est clair tu es chopé
dans comme ça en vrai c'est chaud pour
ta réputation pour tout donc c'est un
peu compliqué donc les joueurs du
circuit on les connaît normalement on
peut y a pas de souci mais on sait
jamais vous voyez on sait jamais
donc voilà allez tiens c'est parti le
Bullet a commencé avec E4 E5 espagnol
pour Caravana pour cette première cette
première
petit rock B5 fou c'est
deux et donc seulement plus un pour
famille donc avec les dessins c'est une
manoeuvre très normale dans cette
position avec un C5 souvent qui va
arriver derrière
tout revu G3
finalement je vois 6
x 3 jours
rouages 7
ça c'est les pollutions qui sont hyper
théoriques c'est celle-là
tours
mais pourquoi pas
j'ai vu les filles les filles elles sont
gavées avec cette troisième place
Championnat du Monde par équipe
là on donne le fou vous voyez c'est pas
étonnant de faire
ce fou bah c'est le fou qui pleure
derrière la structure donc on est bien
content de pouvoir les changer
et donc ok faut prendre c'est ça qui a
été joué parce que fou à 4 c'est pas un
coup là c'est la partie j'aime bien ce
bouffe à 4 parce que ça échange efficace
blanche donc ce fou qui est quand même
extrêmement extrêmement mauvais
qui est car elle est B3
[Musique]
on bloque tout et maintenant vous voyez
ce fou un feutre c'est pas une super
pièce mais un jour arrivant à h6
qui a passé protéger en mac4 pour les
noirs et un cavalier qui tient aussi les
cases j'aime beaucoup la position noire
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs ici faut
acheter
c'est pas du tout comment je progresse
avec les Blancs ce pion qu'il faut
toujours garder
il y a des ruptures des fois
comprise et tout son veille j'ai ça ça
on vit à chaque fois
[Musique]
parce que c'est pas si évident j'aime
beaucoup la potion de noir ici je pense
qu'à tout peut-être peu ici essayer de
mettre une bonne pression sur cette
cette partie peut-être un jour faire F5
je sais pas mais préparer un petit en
tout cas F5 qui a été a été joué alors
présure à E4 probablement
F4
le retour on va tout bien sur la colonne
9 il va y avoir un problème peut-être
plus tard sur sur la colonne F1 qui va
arriver
là c'est pour son typique un peu de
destinienne ou ou le jeu il s'ouvre
ou le jeu s'ouvre ça devient très
difficile à jouer
pour pour les blancs qui se font
attaqués de partout par toutes les
pièces alors moi G6 F4 un jour qui peut
aussi arriver c'est changer beaucoup
plus cavalier attention contre le jeu
quand même
ok gros craquage de avenue ici qui a
perdu une pièce ça va être très vite ça
allait très vite mais la part d'une
pièce
sur une tactique attention attention
c'est peut-être
la F3
comment je parle le match impossible ok
là les gars il y a des il y a des
blender dans chaque partie on dirait
c'est une grosse partie ici un grosse
victoire de la part d'Abdou qui revient
au score dans ce match
même quand c'est gagnant et ben on peut
faire des grosses erreurs c'est hyper
compliqué là par contre pour le Bullet
si vous voulez je vais vous remettre la
jauge
parce que
je remets la jauge
comme là on peut pas trop on peut pas
trop trop parler de position c'est trop
dur je vous mets la jauge ça vous fait
un peu le spectacle avec le score qui
fait que de changer dans tous les sens
ce sera mieux pour vous
alors qu'avez G4 a été joué
Dame des deux c'est très bien comme
pollution le roi noir qui est
extrêmement ouvert ici
ah oui
je pense qu'il faut mettre la jauge
ambulette comme ça
comme on comprend rien de toute façon ça
va trop vite là là je pense que c'est
c'est le bon moment on va tout à l'heure
vous laissez réfléchir un peu entre nous
je comprends bien mais là ici bon ça
coûte un peu
c'est extrêmement compliqué et à
analyser enfin nous on enfin moi je peux
pas je peux pas trop vite
mais au moins on peut
on peut parler un peu
je prends ici ça veut dire
il y avait fourchette je connais la dame
ça va tellement vite qu'on peut pas du
tout analyser donc
si à un moment on peut mettre la jauge
je pense que c'est bien
c'est bien maintenant
et le roi de Kawana qui est complètement
ouvert
[Musique]
après ça reste encore pas évident à
défendre
tac moi je défends ici
H5 on défend le pion qui avait joué
trois fois j'écarte peut-être
non
je dis n'importe quoi
[Musique]
là on va on va voir le roi le roi
déménager
et la tour qui est perdu je pense
et chaque je prends l'âge défends et
Abdou qui prend le lead dans ce match de
Bullet incroyable
c'est complètement incroyable c'est
quand même qu'elle est blanc
je suis désolé j'avais oublié de vous
changer la vue c'est un peu qui vient de
gagner c'est pas Cavana je suis désolé
j'avais oublié de vous changer la vue
et continuer à mettre le score
ça a tellement vite que même moi
j'arrive pas à suivre
allez Huit et demi 9 et demi pour Abdou
qui qui revient en bulletin de zéro pour
l'instant pour lui
en H6 a été joué
non la partie d'avant il avait il avait
les Noirs j'ai oublié de changer le
l'ordre de caméra ce n'est que
mais tout à l'heure il a eu les noirs et
là maintenant enfin tout à l'heure il a
eu les blancs et maintenant il a les
Noirs ça altère à chaque partie tout à
l'heure j'ai fait une erreur j'ai oublié
de le changer sur la caméra
mais ça change rien
qui est perdu
ok dame 2 on va OK
je C4 un jour
en tout cas gros match hein
on pensait à un moment donné qu'on avait
perdu qu'on avait perdu Abdou parce
qu'il était mené de quatre points
dans ce match et maintenant qui il mène
un point c'est incroyable grosse grosse
remontée de Abdou qu'on a quasiment
quasiment enterré
B3 avec
peut être une bonne idée hein
je peux le faire
juste OK
et dire que le vainqueur va jouer
carreau ouais bah après le cas où
toujours prenable très très dur bien
entendu mais
bon à ton là avec cavalier chèque là
c'est du temps facile de carbonate qui
revient à réaliser au score
c'est un match qui tient toutes ses
promesses
ambulette on est à 9 et demi 9 et demi
score complètement égal il reste 19
minutes 50 de Bullet en une plus une
fois 4
en fait tu cherches pas si vous voulez
en
Bullet comme ça les gens qui n'ont pas
tomber donc c'est vraiment l'instinct
c'est l'instinct c'est l'instinct c'est
l'instant donc plus d'effort plus tu
y arrives toi parce que
disons que je veux vraiment
c'est pas vraiment du du calcul
en soit en soi et calcule pas enfin
c'est des bruits dans calculs mais là
ils sont déjà quasiment trois heures de
match donc déjà ils sont fatigués en
plus de ça et ben il y a
il y a aussi le côté
tout ce qui est fatigue tout ce qui est
aussi vous voyez les deux joueurs là
vont avoir le chat Mick qui nous dit
qu'il y a eu 5 huit heures d'affilée
pour chaque joueur il y a eu des gros
chacun a eu son moment de chance enfin
de chance
et puis en fait à un moment donné c'est
compliqué et dans ce cadre on joue
vraiment on joue vraiment
[Musique]
vite
du coup qu'on pense d'apprendre de raser
complète avec un H6
faut prendre
ok à 5 de jouets et ce qui est fou parce
que je trouve ça fou en tout cas c'est
que les gens arrivent toujours à avoir
du jeu quoi ça arrive toujours à créer
des choses foutu ou gagnant les joueurs
regardez il y a deux coups on aurait pu
enterrer car voilà dans la position et
là évidemment il commence à il commence
à avoir du jeu quoi
mais maintenant de nouveau apparemment
la jauge moi ça peut changer mais
dire que la position est quasiment égale
alors que le Renoir était pas ouvert je
trouve ça ouf les gens retrouvent
toujours des possibilités
de toujours réussir à semer le doute et
avoir du contre jeu
de manière ou d'une autre quoi
ça là j'empêche ça
leur gagnant pour abdos
mais je trouve ça ou en fait
tu as réussi à chaque fois à
chaque fois quand même
ils arrivent à se défendre tous les deux
c'est incroyable quand même après bien
sûr
cette capacité à réussir
à
revenir sur cette position là je trouve
ça complètement hallucinant
je trouve ça complètement hallucinant
en fait
dans cette partie
mais c'est bon ça que moi je trouve
vraiment c'est que les gens en fait
perdant ou pas ils vont tout retrouver
toutes les ressources et
ils sont capables de tout quoi
effectivement
dame c'est deux rois G2
et encore une fois une partie
tranquille de la Harley de joueurs avec
ta bille qui est revenu au score encore
avec 17 billes en saveur contre neuf et
demi à 15 minutes de la fin
c'est vraiment un masque à toutes ces
promesses là on avait dit que c'est un
match qui allait être qu'elle est serré
et ben là à 15 minutes on est à un point
d'écart
qui avait annoncé qui avait annoncé un
match très serré évidemment c'est 14,5
pour Fabien
il a un point mais il y a deux parties
il était il était devant il y a deux
parties il avait pris le dessus
incroyable là il vient de se refaire se
refaire on va dire retourner mais c'est
un match super chaud
il y a 18 ans et
enfin pour sa Cabana karena il est à 31
ans
j'ai envie de dire c'est un petit vieux
on va dire
expérimenter quoi enfin bien sûr c'est
pas vieux 31 ans
[Musique]
mais ça fait très longtemps que il est
déjà dans le top niveau ce car voilà
avec les Blancs alors que c'est vrai
qu'il y a plutôt Rohff avec les noirs et
ben il est tout jeune il a 18 ans donc
il entre à peine dans le top niveau
donc un joueur qui est numéro deux
mondial depuis déjà depuis déjà
presque 10 ans quoi
et Abdou qui
est tout petit encore qui est tout
nouveau tout nouveau mais déjà déjà
hyper présent sur les tournois
dans ses résultats de partout
extrêmement impressionnant
iel à éventuellement à champion du monde
j'arrive pas à claquer et là je peux
monter mon roi peut-être
ça aussi ça
tu prends là je prends la
c'est bon
j'ai 5 moi des pions qui avance alors là
c'est la courge de pion mais les blancs
une vitesse
beaucoup trop rapide
mais attention aussi je fais ça tu
arrives assez vite je repars derrière là
et
voilà ça va gagner facile
donc Fabi qui revient avec deux points
d'avance dans ce match encore une fois
famille qui est reprend les commandes du
match
donc il reste 12 minutes de match
encore deux parties enfin deux points
12 minutes tu fais
[Musique]
tu fais ta 3 parties je pense en deux
minutes
mais en plus maintenant je sais pas
c'est du une plus une
mais il y a un incrément donc on va dire
qu'une minute fait environ quatre
parties je pense pas partir environ
trois parties voire 4 ça dépend de
comment ça ça fait le loup donc là il y
a deux points d'écart à 10 minutes de la
fin quasiment
Aboudou est obligé de
de
gagner cette partie là il faut en venir
je pense que le matelas
parce que tout simplement il y aura trop
de retard il y aura trois points à
rattraper avec en plus de temps de la
partie qui sera écoulé ce sera
mathématiquement quasiment impossible
parce que c'est du 1 minute chacun mais
avec un crémant je fais quand même
beaucoup de parties
en une minute
plus une seconde parcours aussi c'est
quand même assez fréquent
[Musique]
on verra en tout cas mais je dirais en
tout trois parties celle-là est de
l'autre
ambulette c'est pile ou face
mais
j'ai envie de dire que
l'avantage de la couleur en fait plus la
cadence est rapide
moi là en face de la couleur est
importante voilà
Arca va laisser 7
[Musique]
c'est clair
c'est clair que on a quand même
ça a l'air d'être complètement terminé
cette histoire je crois que Fabi est
perdant les gars tout réel perdu si je
roule le pion je perds
comment je défends ça je crois que ça
bille est perdant tu reprends F7 tu
reprends tu reprends
roi je suis te forcée et dame j'ai
quatre peut-être
venir ici c'est Matt tu boules ici il y
a pas d'échec en bas ni là j'ai rangé
deux plus d'échec et là vous voyez que
même là trouver des coups quoi d'un
point ici je prends là je prends là ok
abondant
donc toujours un point d'écart entre ces
deux joueurs je vais mettre le score à
jour d'Abdou qui passe la barre des 10
dans ce match 17 à 11h30
allez un point de retard il reste 8
minutes 45 l'équivalent d'environ deux
parties et demi de partie voire 3 ça va
dépendre vraiment s'ils font une partie
longue ou pas
mais ce serait bien enfin moi j'aimerais
bien pour l'intérêt du match que que
Abdou gagne la prochaine partie gagne
celle-là
pour que tout ce soit la dernière ça
serait beau
ça serait beau tout ça
[Musique]
c'est les jouets
prises et pousser d'autres D4 un truc
comme ça c'est de l'ouvrir la position
avec une position de la paire de fou ici
les blancs doivent essayer de jouer pour
l'ouverture de la position
trop bien été joué et Fabi il a compris
il bloque tout pour pas que les fous
adversent jouer c'est marrant ce qui
fait quand même
ce fou qui pourra un jour
mais là j'aime bien les Noirs parce que
j'ai l'impression que l'attaque ici avec
F4 dans mes 6 tout ça j'ai l'impression
que ça va plutôt favoriser les noirs
arrivent à se défendre ils font des
parties de malade mentaux quoi
regardez souffrant puis on prend et
qu'elle va les prendre H3 elle était
aussi une possibilité là je la comprends
H3
c'est moche mais je défends H3 je vois
pas comment je défends je crois
différemment avec G5 mais qui a 5 c'est
chaud il y a 600 OK
avec demi-h4
ouais c'est hyper chaud
c'est hyper hyper hyper chaud
[Musique]
allez 20 secondes chacun tu apprends H3
taf 3 avec les jouets
je la squash je sais pas
j'ai deux peut-être mais voilà j'ai
l'impression
ok c'est chaud là qui va se cacher en C3
et on a l'impression quand même que le
roi blanc c'est quand même bien
bien caché j'aurais plus grand chose
pour les Noirs mais quand même deux
pions
de pions le câble qui va venir aussi pas
si facile encore faire attention
avec il va revenir en Descartes
probablement
qui s'est planqué
ça a pas grand chose qui a value 2
attention H5 peut-être va être joué pour
faire H4 et faire la fourchette n'a pas
été joué malheureusement
la F3 on fait le tour des 4
il reste 7 secondes chacun il reste 5
minutes sur le temps
donc il y a encore une partie après
celle-là
et voir encore une dernière peut-être
mais si karena gagne celle-là et bien il
va garder deux points d'avance je pense
que ce sera une très très difficile pour
Abdou je pense qu'à Abdou il doit pas
perdre celle-là même une nulle c'est pas
mal au moins il aura encore une dernière
partie pour cette gagner mais je vois
pas comment il peut la garder on pousse
le pion je pense que c'est juste perdu
complètement
incroyable ok famille qui gagne cette
partie
bien la partie et qui gagne je pense
quasiment quasiment le match parce qu'il
reste 445
en fait
si
c'est 12 et demi pardon j'ai fait
n'importe quoi
j'ai fait n'importe
12 et demi alors si
dans cette partie là on va être si Abdou
arrive à gagner cette partie là et que
le timer il y a au moins une seconde et
ben il va recommencer une partie donc là
Abdou pour l'obligation de gagner cette
partie avant de avant que le timer 3-0
et ensuite gagner la dernière partie
pour arriver à un départage
s'il y a 12 pas fait pas 202 et ben il
sera élimine la compétition et c'est
Fabi karena qui jouera en quart de
finale contre au Patriote carunakamura
qui est vraiment
peut-être le meilleur joueur du circuit
dans ce format là avec Magnus
c'est très juste hallucinant alors G4
ça me prend H3
tours en tout cas
Abdou peut s'en vouloir il a perdu pas
mal de parties assez bêtement quand même
dans ce dans ce match je parle pas du
Bullet je parle de général il a perdu
beaucoup de parties sur des tactiques en
un coup un truc qui me lave quasiment
jamais mais bon je pense ça arrive quand
tu es fatigué et du coup c'est vrai que
là maintenant il a réussi à revenir
hyper bien dans ce match il était à
moins à moins 4 mois il a réussi à très
bien revenir et malgré tout ça reste
chaud et donc imaginez-vous ce qui est
pas donné tous ces points
un peu bêtement il aurait pu peut-être
avoir un sérieux avantage sur son
adversaire tiens à 5
h qui va s'ouvrir et le roi d'Abdou qui
peut en souffrir un peu les conséquences
ton congélateur qui reste 2 minutes 30
dans ce match il faut que
Abdou gagne très très vite
on va jouer F3 la position qui est qui
est mieux pour les voir il y a un plan
de plus mais est-ce qu'il aura le temps
de la gagner ça c'est notre histoire il
reste deux minutes
mais il faut qu'il garde cette partie
mais en plus il gagne
avant que le temps soit à zéro
tour 3 a pas mal quand même
des trois à cinq à quatre sûrement
c'est pas que moi j'en fais chaque 4
embêtant
[Musique]
une minute 30 je sais pas s'il va y
arriver
je suis pas sûr de tout qu'il y arrive
le pion qui va arriver en A3 échec et de
ça qui pourra essayer d'aller manger le
pion c'est le plus on va trop loin
il empêche pour des 7
ok il a pris le pion
j'ai peur ce pion qui va avancer là
il reste une minute
une minute 15
pour gagner la partie même si gagne et
qu'il reste et qui reste plus de temps
et ben c'est perdu il a deux points
rattraper
deux points c'est énorme
la tour qui bouge plus
et chaque étourdin incroyable le la tour
qui est perdu et ici maintenant ça va
être terminé je peux même peut-être
sacrifié la tour sur le cavalier
et c'est famille qui va gagner cette
partie et c'est Fabi qui va
je mangerai
ce match
moi je mange un cavalier même
pas la tête
et je suis avec la
la fourchette ça a pris une fourchette
moi je me serais pris une capture pour
la pour la pièce mais tous les pions
tombent et ça va être perdu ça va être
abandon et Abdou qui va devoir
se résigner
du genre
c'est perdu c'est perdu et qu'un voisin
qui va se qualifier mais maintenant il
faut qu'elle me lancer la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il va bien dans le prochain
match donc très ennemis en tout cas à 10
et demi à 11,5
dans ce match pour fabuleux carbona qui
va se qualifier pour le premier quart de
finale et regardez on a un deuxième
quart de finale qui est fait avec
Nakamura en tête de liste tout là-haut
qui va jouer contre carwana donc son
compatriote numéro 2 mondial et bon
après même si le numéro de mondial
Nakamura c'est vraiment le genre à
abattre un c'est le joueur qui est le
plus fort du circuit avec Magnus qui
sera en bas de tableau donc on a la
caméra ici qui vient s'ajouter ici voilà
ça rime ni à Sarine
qui va joue entre le gagnant de mvl
goutesh qui aura lieu demain à 13h30
donc demain 13h30 soyez présent un sur
tout ce qu'on va faire ce sera avec
Kevin bandit et ensuite on aura aussi 45
minutes demain j'ai pas l'horaire je
pense à tout en soirée personne ne dites
demain qui jouera contre nepo et rigazir
un épaule qui remplace ding ding qui est
absent du tournoi qui était de base
prévu et qui me tient pas leur mvl très
hertrand et Magnus je pense vers 19h
mais je suis pas sûr à 100% revoir un
peu un peu tout ça en tout cas merci à
tous je souhaite avant de caméra merci à
tous d'avoir suivi d'avoir suivi le
stream et puis moi je vous dis à demain
demain sera pas avec moi ça sera avec
Kevin bandit mais à demain Sanchez comme
et pour ma part ben je sais pas encore
peut-être les autres matchs je sais pas
encore si votre sollicité pour commenter
tout ça en tout cas merci à tous d'avoir
suivi l'événement bonne soirée à tous et
bon courage pour pour demain pour le
travail etc et je vous dis à très
bientôt ciao ciao